faut dire que on partait nos québec qui
était clairement sous scolarisés à
l'époque de toutes les provinces du
canada le québec avait le plus grand
retard à l'âge de 15 ans la majorité des
gens avaient quitté l'école et 50% des
jeunes se rendait jusqu'à la septième
année les noirs américains à l'époque
avait une année de scolarisation moyenne
de plus que les francophones du québec
et pas besoin de vous dire que les noirs
américains l'époque vivait pour la
défense des droits civiques il y avait
la ségrégation donc le québec avait un
énorme retard donc de créer un ministère
de l'éducation de rendre accessible à
tous de dire bailly pu y avoir des
petites écoles de rang faut qu'on ait
des écoles mieux organisés 50% des
institutrices avait pas de diplôme
alors il fallait restructurer tout ça et
c'est ce qui a fait pas le gérer la joie
avec une résistance de l'église les
évêques voyait bien qu'ils avaient plus
les moyens de financer le réseau de
collèges classiques qui était déjà
élitiste mais il y tenait quand même
cette influence parce que les évêques
était l'église catholique était
l'organisatrice la société québécoise on
était dans une société ultra catholique
donc pas de gérer la joie qui était
lui-même un catholique qui avait même
été l'avocat de la fédération des
collèges classiques dans des années 50
donc n'était pas perçu au début comme un
ennemi du clergé mais c'est un homme du
bien commun et puis il a insisté pour
conseil des ministres s'étaient pas
évident parce que dites-vous que ancrée
m ca d'éducation c'est aller chercher
une bonne part du budget de l'état et
les autres ministres n'est pas ça parce
que cela rend lever des fonds alors il a
dû par avec une grande ténacité mais
avec un objectif qui est un noble en
fait c'était donner une éducation ou aux
jeunes québécois et québécoises et
québécois parce que des collèges
classiques
il y avait peut-être 90 collège
classique au québec à l'époque à peine
une dizaine dont les jeunes filles et
les jeunes filles s'étaient pas les
mêmes cours s'il y avait des cours de
chimie
on faisait de la chimie alimentaire pour
la cuisine et je caricature pas c'était
comme ça il y avait certes un cours de
science qu'on ne donnait pas aux jeunes
filles parce qu' il allait la maison on
avait besoin de reprendre
obligé que les femmes aient accès aux
mêmes types d'éducation même niveau
d'éducation tout oui absolument
féministe aussi oui absolument et la
croissance du niveau de scolarisation
des jeunes femmes au québec c'est la
plus grande
le plus grand succès de la réforme de
l'éducation surtout quand on vient des
résultats aujourd'hui en regardant qui
fréquentent l'université majeur opus
d'un jeune femme que john que john
holmes aujourd'hui alors c'est un succès
sur toute la ligne
et ça augmente et pour l'économie du
québec c'était essentiel de que le
québec avait une économie défaillante la
majorité à l'époque on disait canadienne
français a été dominé économiquement on
n'avait que beaucoup de jeunes
d'ouvriers qui était peu éduquée alors
pas le gêner la joie pourquoi on lui
rend hommage aujourd'hui ce qui l'a
amené des réformes structurantes sur non
pas une seule génération comme sujet
d'un chariot disait mais sur les autres
générations moi je suis la première
génération des polyvalentes mes enfants
maintenant ça va de soi que beaucoup
vont aller à l'université de génération
en génération
notre système d'éducation afin que notre
société devenue une société qui est
capable de rivaliser avec les grandes
sociétés développées depuis c'est pour
ça qu'on le voit comme un pilier aussi
content de la révolution tranquille on
est vraiment passés d'une époque à une
autre et il fait partie de ceux qui ont
largement contribué lui dans son cas par
le biais de cet accès à l'éducation et
c'était un pressing parce que jean
lesage t'as pas trop pressé y est ils
subissaient l'influencent d éveil qu'un
bon le cardinal léger était possible
avait avait une ouverture mais vous
aviez certains évêques dans certaines
régions qui étaient très conservateur et
qui voulait pas laisser le pouvoir
l'influencé qu'ils avaient ils paul
gérin lajoie insistait et quand il l'a
formé
la fameuse commission parent du nom de
monseigneur pas renvoyer c'est un
monseigneur bon millier tel vice recteur
à l'universel aval
c'était quand même un homme qui avait
une ouverture à l'égard du savoir si
vous voulez objectif vous de savoir
universitaire mac en informer la
commission parent il a été choisir les
commissaires aussi avec l'aide du
premier ministre et il s'est assuré que
les rapports soient déposés rapidement
parce que produire un rapport y en a eu
cinq sa durée 5 ans il s'est assuré à
chaque fois que le rapport soit suivi
qu'ils soient appliquées pas besoin de
vous dire aujourd'hui on en a vu
beaucoup des commissions oui on a vu
beaucoup des rapports sont ramassés sur
des tablettes
oui dans le cas de la commission parent
pas tout a été mise en oeuvre bien sûr
mais à 80 %
ce fut le cas on va continuer maintenant
avec les témoignages il ya quelques
minutes à peine la ministre mélanie joly
a témoigné on va l'écouter tout de suite
mais en fait c'est un des piliers de la
révolution tranquille et moi en tant que
jeunes issus de la génération des baby
boomers
on voit à quel point son legs a été
immense
en tant que ministre la francophonie
internationale aussi ce qui marque c'est
que ce que paul gérin lajoie était en
mesure de faire céder le début des
années 60 il crée des ponts avec entre
le québec et la france mais aussi avec
d'autres pays francophones
un moment même où l'idée de francophonie
était en émergence et donc en ce sens
cela les ouïes le pilier de la
révolution tranquille mais il est aussi
un des piliers de la francophonie
internationale
merci on parle de ses réussites de ses
succès il a connu sa part de revers
aussi comme milieu ou même comme
candidat oui le début de sa carrière
politique il faut le dire dans les
années 50 sa pas été facile
il s'est présenté dans vaudreuil il a
perdu les élections générales et il a
perdu à l'élection partielle suivante il
voulait être chef du parti libéral et sa
femme un message l'iran le premier
ménage de s'instruire vient d'arriver et
qu une écoute en le maintenant sa vision
d'un québec et éduquer ou les gens
avaient une
rayonnement partout dans le monde en
tant qu'enseignant tant que québécois
encore jeune je sais qu'il a
profondément marqué mon histoire est
celle de nous tous au québec et c'est un
moment pour pour s'en souvenir et pourra
célébrer tout ce qu'il a fait
on peut gérer la joie aux hommes un
chèque éducation et à tous merci
beaucoup
vous remarquerez que le premier ministre
trudeau a dit en tant qu'enseignant
parce qu'effectivement il un passé
d'enseignant alors là dedans ça le
touche particulièrement quand on parle
de paul gérin lajoie parce qu'évidemment
il en on vient de dire avec pierre tout
ce qu'il a fait comme contribution pour
créer un ministère de santé pour avoir
des enseignants éduqué mais aussi au
delà de ce que ça rayonne hors des
frontières du québec aussi avec la
fondation paul gérin-lajoie un petit mot
là-dessus justement pierre pas ce qu'il
se passe et de politiciens et il a
quitté finalement des dans des
conditions pour une somme en facile non
plus il a été ministre voyez-vous de 60
à 70 6 à partir de la création d'une
scène l'éducation donc devient ministre
de l'éducation en 66 le parti libéral à
la surprise de plusieurs paires c'est
d'union nationale de daniel johnson il a
beaucoup vont reprocher pas de gérer la
joie les raisons de la défaite
jean lesage vous dire c'est l'éducation
qui nous a fait perdre d'autres
ministres qui ont perdus vont le dire
parce que évidemment samedi un ensemble
de réformes
ça dérange et parfois les écoles de rien
était démuni mais de mettre des autobus
scolaires jaune c'est là que ça a
commencé dans les robes les amener très
loin s'est inquiété des parents donc il
a fallu faire bon les polyvalentes on y
trouvait un petit peu trop grosse et
devaient être moins rose
il ya eu beaucoup de réformes qui ont
dérangé les taxes scolaires augmentent
et donc on a reproché à paul gérin
lajoie ce qu'on reconnaît aujourd'hui
comme de grandes réalisations et la
défaite qu'il a dû vivre avec
au point où il a démissionné à environ 2
3 ans plus tard en 69
parce que bon il espérait peut-être
prendre la relève de jean lesage
mais ils n'avaient plus aucun appui dans
le parti compte tenu de du poids de la
défaite qu'on lui attribue et on va
écouter maintenant daniel top quitté
moyens sont tous dans les années
100 devant les consuls et j'ai remarqué
récemment qu'il avait fait une
proposition audacieuse il voulait de
télé-québec de sa propre constitution en
1967 l'avait fait des propositions comme
celle à son parti donc un homme qui
proposait sa en 1967 est un homme de
vision il faut compléter son oeuvre
maintenant
ap
esi et bonjour le jeu
ce n'est pas aux normes
qu est ce qu on pourrait d'abord
évidemment ça avec une grande tristesse
aujourd'hui qu'on souligne le départ de
paul gérin lajoie puisque c'est un grand
pionnier canadien en grandvaux tease en
visionnaire il était un passionné
d'éducation que je suis aussi passionné
de l'aide internationale passionnés tout
court
si vous le connaissiez paul gérin lajoie
il a souhaité des changements profonds
dans notre société et je le sais qu'il a
opéré toute sa vie et c'est seulement
pour le bien-être le bien commun et
l'épanouissement de notre société
personnellement j'ai eu la chance de
côtoyer pas que j'aurai la joie surtout
dans les débuts des années 90 lorsqu'il
commence ay laventure de la dictée pgl
qui comme vous le savez rassemble des
jeunes d'âge scolaire à travers le monde
pour améliorer la maîtrise la langue
française mais aussi pour comprendre on
est mieux sensibiliser les enjeux
globaux auxquels nous faisons face alors
j'étais comme astronaute marraine de
certaines des des activités de la dictée
pgl et c'est drôle à dire que beaucoup
plus tard mon fils qui est adolescent
aujourd'hui a fait la dictée pgl à
l'école primaire l'école secondaire donc
son parcours sa contribution perdure
nous ne l'oublierons jamais
je remercie j'ai pardon vous avez
aveugle et en anglais la même chose avec
plaisir le nombre d'enfants qu'ils ont
fait ça dit elle est un événement
d'ailleurs dans la vie d'un enfant mais
as appris cette proportion international
qui est éblouissante et c'est une des
raisons d'ailleurs pour lesquels on
retrouve des dignitaires qui viennent de
la francophonie entre autres des gens
qui viennent d'afrique qui sont présents
aujourd'hui pour lui rendre un dernier
hommage
on va écouter tout de suite ce que
l'ancien maire de montréal denis coderre
avait à dire c'était il ya quelques
minutes
est ce que j'allais un jour pour moi
c'était parce qu'il dit parce que tant
au niveau du côté
c'est une amie c'est une amie japonaise
c'est quelqu'un
mais section plus d'experts j'ai
toujours l'adolescence est apparu
c'est quelqu'un qui vous
absurde
je pense qu'aujourd'hui
département fondu il a d'ailleurs permis
mais j'ai réussi
c'est nous simples que laisser un legs
pour le départ qui avait été maire de
oui tout à fait d'accord avec mes
ambitions de rapatrier aussi une chance
à votre histoire
non mais j'ai trouvé je trouve et puis
si je pense aussi à françois pas ce
qu'il dément
sur même
sa maman
[Musique]
dans c'est quelqu'un qui parle c'est ça
ma et pluie qu'on savait
souvent aussi de l'adopter
maintenant vous allez entendre le
ministre pierre arcand on écoute à
l'instant lundi également dans
lesquelles il a été fortement impliqué
et moi je peux vous dire qu'on a fait
aussi des journées de réflexion dans
notre formation politique et monsieur
gérer la joie était jusqu'à récemment la
extrêmement impliqué aussi alors c'est
quelqu'un qui avait une vision et qui
pour moi représente évidemment
l'excellence c'est un grand québécois
merci pierre quelques personnes viennent
de faire référence à la dictée pgl et
aussi à l'acdi donc sa contribution
internationale ici parlant justement de
ce rayonnement international en parle
d'une certaine doctrine de paul gérin
lajoie ici pour donner une place sur la
scène internationale au québec et les
précurseurs de celui il avait fait des
études il avait été choisi pour être
boursier oxford en angleterre et il a
fait des études supérieures et est
devenu spécialiste du droit
constitutionnel et en 1965 devant
plusieurs consuls
il va prononcer un discours à montréal
et il va dire qu' il va définir pour la
province de québec une personnalité
internationale
il va affirmer que les pouvoirs du
québec
éducation santé et tous peuvent avoir
une extension au niveau international on
peut lorsqu'on parle éducation même si
on in province avoir accès signé des
traités avoir des discussions il va
d'ailleurs signer des premiers entente
avec la france à cet égard là et donc à
ottawa on va être un peu un puce surpris
par ce qu'il y avait comme un espace qui
était mal définis avec la doctrine
gérin-lajoie il va doter le québec d'une
personnalité nationale et c'est pas rien
parce qu'en même temps il ya des
ouvertures de délégations du québec avec
la france et dans d'autres pays
et séduit c'est lui qui a porté sa et
tout à l'heure on entendait monsieur
train de parler d'un projet de
constituer tout c'est que il va
continuer même à la fin des années 60
après la défaite du parti dans
l'opposition le parti galette
redéfinir une position constitutionnelle
et lui vont proposer le statut
particulier alors rené lévesque arrive
avec la souveraineté-association rené
lévesque et dans le parti libéral à ce
moment là et lui c'est le statut
particulier donc donné en s'inspirant
trop de la doctrine sur la position
internationale d'une province donc de
dire le québec pourrait avoir compte
tenu de son passé sa culture son
histoire un peuple fondateur du canada
donc un statut particulier
mais à l'époque ça fonctionnerait pas
parce que vous avez un nouvel élu qui
est en train de monter qui s'appelle
pierre elliott trudeau à le père du
président actuel et pierre-elliot
trudeau pour lui il se moque du statut
particulier parce que le canada doit
avoir un gouvernement central et ou
alors vous voyez que c'est le début de
nos familles politiques qui vont
s'étendre sur 30-40 ans mais pas le
gérer la joint donc à tenter de jouer un
rôle a tenté d'amener une voie mitoyenne
mais qui n'a pas donné des résultats et
leur par la suite la politique de lui
laissant plus de place
il a décidé c'est le creux en fédérale
qui lui offre monsieur trudeau bond le
plus d'abord un poste de vice président
d'une commission sur l'inflation mais
rapidement on lui dit
l'acdi agence canadienne de
développement international existe
pouvez vous diriger son il va le faire
pendant environ sept à huit ans et la
sas a vraiment marqué un autre tournant
dans sa carrière c'est un homme il
disait lui-même il a eu cinq carrières
finalement alors ressources d'un moment
très important l'acdi ça nous amène vers
justement la fondation paul gérin lajoie
et la fameuse dictée on voit pierre karl
péladeau qui s'avance ici vers les
micros on va l'écouter tout de suite
immense que paul gérin lajoie a laissé
au québec communication
lorsque le premier ministre d'ailleurs
je pensais dans sa formule
l'émancipation l'émancipation est
utilisé dans les volets référence à
nelson mandela je pense que c'est une
très bonne référence effectivement
ça nous a permis de nous projeter dans
l'art moderne
et puis aujourd'hui si nous avons une
collectivité aussi riche n'avons que les
collectivités aussi juste entre
certainement quitter du temps quand vers
la justice et l'équité c'est paul gérin
lajoie s'est positionné ses positions
ici aussi certainement bon est ce qu'ils
sont on doit retenir évidemment un
certain nombre de choses on doit il
attendre les prioriser
oui peut-être que oui peut-être que non
moi ce que je retiens aussi surtout
s'ils sont donc tout le travail qui est
fait pour pour le milieu de l'éducation
que les québécois sorte de cette torpeur
un petit peu historique qui était la
leur qui vous a permis effectivement
d'énergie de nous émanciper de réussir
domaine alors voilà on dit que le
premier ministre philippe couillard est
sur le point aussi de se présenter
devant nos micros on le voit ici
d'ailleurs le qui s'avance en compagnie
de sa conjointe
alors on va prendre le temps de l'écouté
aussi un peu plus tôt on a pu
nos collègues ont pu entendre la nomma
c'est gabriel nadeau dubois
on va vous présenter leurs commentaires
dans les prochaines minutes mais d'abord
elles ont écouté philippe couillard
premier ministre du québec
moi j'ai les dix ans je le répète on le
répétera tantôt probablement le grand
bâtisseur de la modernité québécois
c'est l'éducation émanciper les
québécois dans les années 60 les a
propulsés vers la modernité il faut
jamais l'oublier mais faut pas oublier
non plus son rôle en relations
internationales en développement
international de plusieurs façons et
pour longtemps
il ya deux choses moi qui m'ont touché
hier parce que je venais à la chapelle
ardente je vais peut-être les
relativement vaudrait peut-être un peu
tantôt d'abord beaucoup d'enseignants et
d'enseignantes sont venus présenter
leurs respects également sa famille et
bien sûr j'ai rencontré j'ai vu à son
revers du veston ceux qui ont vu hier le
cas
le corps de monsieur gérin lajoie avait
l'épinglette de la dictée et une de ses
petites filles qui a insisté pour lui
mettre sur son veston je trouve ça
touchant commun comme comme l'épisode
familiale dont mais également qui parle
à l'ensemble des personnes qui ont souri
la dictée alors on va lui présenter nos
respects la france au nom de tout le
monde
c'est elle
c'est émouvant enfer d'entendre ces
témoignages l'homme ce quia russie qui
fait référence à la petite fille de paul
gérin lajoie qui voulait vraiment que
son grand-père avait dans son dernier
repos avec ce symbole de cette dictée
pgl parlons-en de cette dictée justement
il est il a donc bâti cette fondation la
fondation à son nom en fait avec
d'anciens collègues ou si on lui a
proposé d'être à la tête de cette
fondation
justement l'objectif de la fondation est
l'importance qu'elle prit alors la
fondation était de s'assurer que
l'éducation soit partagé par plus est là
lui avaient une vision beaucoup
international donc d'aller aider les
pays africains d'abord et ensuite
beaucoup haïti dont plusieurs pays ont
profité de l'aide de la fondation pour
aider à former des professeurs pour
ouvrir des bibliothèques pour former oui
je le dis à des professeurs mais ouvrir
des classes donner des livres et ensuite
de favoriser de sensibiliser la
population canadienne québécoise à la
réalité de la solidarité internationale
donc les dictées bien sûr c'était la
fierté de la langue française qui a
toujours été important pour monsieur
gérin lajoie
mais c'était aussi de cesser de
développer des opérations de parrainage
la fondation a s'est assuré qu'il ya des
beaucoup de gens d'ici qui parraine des
écoles en afrique et au donc pour ouvrir
là je dirais un courant de solidarité
des très jeunes dès le plus jeune âge
pour réaliser que dans d'autres pays on
n'a pas les mêmes facilités là et cette
fondation la petite anecdote
intéressante qu'elle quitte l'acdi les
gens savent pas trop quoi lui donner
comme cadeau ils vont lui donner une
charte et c'est l'achat d'une fondation
et bien sûr y avait pas l'argent avec
mon adjoint de monter la chape fondation
paul gérin lajoie et vous aurez donc les
documents et ben il suffit que vous
présentez genre de choses là cette âme
notre dynamique et y ont rapidement à
partir de la chappe développer et il en
a fait une structure réelle
la pérennité c'est impressionnant le
sauve iront vers 70 1977 qui s'activent
avec cette fondation
la dictée existe depuis les années 90 à
m'en faire presque 30 ans l'aide
internationale l'on parle de maintenant
de centaines de milliers d'enfants qui
ont pu profiter de politiques de
campagne pour favoriser de
l'alphabétisation
alors voyez c'est un homme qui d'abord
s'est engagée par la politique pour les
québécois pour la jeunesse et qui a
étendu sa générosité à l'international
alors c'est assez exemplaire tout à fait
c'est un rayonnement qu'il n'est pas
seulement nos frontières d'où la
présence aussi aujourd'hui de jeunes qui
vont été dans cette cérémonie pour faire
un clin d'oeil fr on rappelle justement
à cette fameuse dictée pgl qui donne
encore aujourd'hui le goût à nos enfants
de performer de se dépasser
parce qu'on sait qu'au départ les ducs
tu sais pas très très populaire mais la
façon dont pas gérer les représentent et
ça c'est un jeu c'est amusant c'est une
autre forme de compétition et pas
nécessairement sportive celle là mais
une compétition avec les mousses inspiré
le chanteur y visiter qu'on va entendre
d'ailleurs pendant cette cérémonie et
qui avait composé la demande de paul
gérin lajoie une chanson justement quel
est dans l'esprit de cette dictée pgl on
peut entendre maintenant des
représentants de québec solidaire aussi
qui sont présentés aujourd'hui manon
massé et gabriel nadeau dubois
d'un côté je pense que si on est là
aujourd'hui c'est parce que y'a un
visionnaire un visionnaire qui aimait
beaucoup travaillé en équipe d'ailleurs
qui donne énormément pour le québec et
pour nous c'est vraiment important
d'être là parce que le projet que porte
et nous suggérait la joie tant au niveau
de l'éducation presse en général mais
aussi l'éducation à l'international
l'éducation populaire
c'était un homme qui avait une vision où
ce que le peuple
la connaissance du peuple et des
centrales répondre c'est super important
d'être s'étaient rencontrés à une
reprise moi ce que ce que je retiens de
la mémoire de paul gérin lajoie c'est un
homme qui a fait au peuple québécois le
plus beau des cadeaux
celui de l' éducation publique gratuite
laïque humaniste c'est le cadeau de la
liberté au fond que monsieur gérin
lajoie a fait au peuple du québec large
très comptable très ému d'être ici
aujourd'hui
il y avait un petit côté d'une certaine
façon révolutionnaire tentant de la
révolution tranquille jeudi
il faut avoir des nerfs pour être
capable de passer autour de soi de la
résistance il y en avait dans son parti
aussi à l'époque oui bah et écouter
qu'un la commission parent dépose son
premier rapport en avril 63 pour dire il
faut qu'on propose de créer un ministère
de l'éducation alors gérin lajoie est
satisfait c'est ce qu'on voulait
entendre
et là il ya un document qui appuie tout
ça le premier ministre monsieur lesage
qu'il rencontre lui dit palatin pu
prenons notre temps il faut que la
population s'habitue les évêques doivent
digérer le morceau c'est quand même pas
évident prenons prenons notre temps et
dont un au nom des gens parce qu'il se
tutoyaient si on fait passer en
septembre c'est toute une génération il
pensait comme ça c'est tout une jeune et
toute une cohorte de jeunes qui n'auront
pas l'information
ils ont retard pour leur avenir leurs
possibilités il faut faire tout de suite
force de conviction le projet de loi
déposé en juin mêlant les évêques
s'agite d un sister catholique
certains gens de la personne de sociétés
plus conservateur si vous voulez alors
au mois de juillet jean lesage retire le
budget le projet de loi est là à la
colère bien sûr de paul gérin lajoie
pour se donner un peu de temps mais là
ça a été une lutte donc c'est pas les
tuer ils ont redéposé l'année suivante
mais il ya au prix de tensions parce
qu'elle est digne d'intérêt qui n'honore
pas le combatif un révolutionnaire
quelqu'un qui ne cessent de ces battues
pour ses idées claires la cérémonie est
en train de commencer
alors on va l'écouter avec nous en
direct mesdames messieurs vous noterez
la présence de la musique très présente
pendant cette cérémonie
johanne blouin chante elle était
accompagnée par gregory charles
il y aura plusieurs prestations ont les
côtes ensemble
ce faire
[Musique]
mon fils quand salem
misère
il souffre est la sienne
[Musique]
oh
cobra
mais pas toi qui m'as
romo
pas moi
mon pauvre enfant à ma vie
[Musique]
on
oh
m
[Musique]
mon fils est beau
depuis
je suis déjà s'y fier
bibi
ils sauront radès de personnes
c'est mon bien
moroni que mieux sur la terre
si dieu
le soir au sacre
[Musique]
tél
je du mali à 100
et sow
ce mois c'est une malle
qui veut
mourir pour son enfant
[Musique]
marie
oh
v mardi
[Musique]
mais
m
obama
la fin
sa prière
ainsi
lien
tout bien faire
touchante vente et ça me sert
[Musique]
à
gare de moi pour que j'espère
oh
fille
d'enfants des sourires
m6
merci
me
[Musique]
c'est toi
qui sauve mon enfant
[Musique]
marie
où
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez vu mesdames messieurs lâche
avec christian lépine c'est lui donc il
va présider cette cérémonie vous avez pu
voir aussi à l'entrée il a salué les
membres de la famille de paul gervais
lajoie son fils entre autres françois
quitte à la tête maintenant ta fondation
paul gérin lajoie
il y aura tout au long de la cérémonie
plusieurs témoignages entre autres celui
du premier ministre du québec fait les
couilles art écoutons la suite de la
cérémonie la paix soit avec vous chers
frères et soeurs nous sommes réunis afin
de prier dieu pour pas gérer la joie
nous pensons à son épouse andrée décédé
en février dernier nous sommes venus
entourer dans notre affection
notre sympathie de notre amitié ceux et
celles qui sont dans la peine
je vous salue chère famille de paul des
enfants françois avec tina damart avec
line sylvie avec yves dominique avec
jacques les petits enfants les arrières
petits enfants tous les membres de la
famille et amis ont ces funérailles
nationales
je veux saluer la généreuse présence de
monsieur le premier ministre du québec
philippe couillard madame la gouverneure
générale du canada julie payette
monsieur le premier ministre
canada justin trudeau monsieur le
lieutenant gouverneur du québec michel
doyon
madame la mairesse de montréal valérie
la plante
madame et monsieur les premiers
ministres
madame la secrétaire général de
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie monsieur le président de
l'assemblée nationale madame la vice
première ministre et mesdames et
messieurs les ministres du gouvernement
du québec
mesdames et messieurs les ministres du
gouvernement du canada
mesdames et messieurs membres des corps
diplomatiques et consulaires
mesdames et messieurs les chefs de
l'opposition officielle et du deuxième
groupe d'opposition
mesdames et messieurs les députés
sénateurs et anciens parlementaires
mesdames et messieurs les élus
municipaux dames et messieurs distingués
invités frères et soeurs dans le christ
avant de poursuivre la célébration
liturgique je vous invite à entendre les
témoignages qui vont maintenant vous
êtes intéressés vous pouvez vous asseoir
nous allons pouvoir entendre monsieur le
premier ministre du québec
mesdames messieurs les enfants de paul
gérin lajoie françois bernard sylvie
dominique petits enfants arrière petits
enfants proches et amis de la famille je
vous présente les condoléances de tout
le peuple du québec
monseigneur lépine avec la mort de paul
gérin lajoie un chapitre de notre
histoire se termine mais nous savons
tous et toutes qu'il continuera
d'inspirer le grand livre de notre
avenir
lorsque disparaissent des figures
marquantes de notre aventure commune
on se rappelle avec gratitude leur
contribution au progrès du québec et
leurs oeuvres centre alors dans notre
mémoire
mais de paul gérin lajoie et soit
difficile de parler au passé parce que
son legs appartient à l'intemporel et à
l'universel de tout temps la
transmission des connaissances et
l'éducation ont été la clé du progrès
des peuples encore vrai aujourd'hui
ce sera encore vrai dans certains car la
connaissance soit toujours une quête
chaque question qui trouvera réponse
s'ouvrira sur dix nouvelles pourquoi
commun et donc pourquoi pas cette quête
permanente et exaltant de savoir paul
gérin lajoie l'a rendu accessible à tous
les enfants du québec
tous les enfants et toutes les enfants
du québec guillaume il a démocratisé
l'éducation en réunissant les écoles de
rein du collège classique les
universités sous une autorité civile
il a établi le principe de l'égalité des
chances et de la gratuité scolaire l'a
mis sur pied la commission parent a
constitué un véritable réseau de
l'éducation dont l'ambition demeure
permettre à n'importe quel enfant
d'atteindre la plus haute marche
de dévoiler le trésor que chacun chacune
porte en soi et cela pour tous les
enfants les garçons et les filles
beaucoup d'entre elles sont d'ailleurs
venus hier dire leurs connaissances son
impact et transformateurs sous son
impulsion de québécois ou accompli l'un
des plus formidables rattrapage en
éducation au monde
de tout temps également le progrès des
peuples a été liée à leur capacité de
coopérer de commerce et d'échangés de se
projeter dans le monde
là aussi paul gérin lajoie a changé la
trajectoire du québec
c'est la doctrine gérin-lajoie l'assise
politique de l'action internationale du
québec
elle se résume simplement ce qui est de
compétence québécoise chez nous et de
compétence québécoise par tous ces chats
tête sur cette bulle québec s'est doté
d'un réseau maintenant de 32
représentations à l'étranger et que le
québec entretient des relations avec des
gouvernements du monde entier
cette philosophie aurait été une sorte
de mise au monde du québec un tremplin
dont bénéficient aujourd'hui notre
jeunesse nos entrepreneurs nos créateurs
et nos scientifiques
après son retrait de la vie politique
paul gérin lajoie a dirigé l'agencé
canadienne de développement
international
étendant dans les pays en voie de
développement et particulièrement en
afrique francophone
sa mission éducative puis il a pris les
rênes de la fondation paul gérin-lajoie
voué à l'éducation à travers le monde et
dont la dictée pgl bien sûr et
l'étendard le plus connu hier j'ai vu
qu'il portait une épinglette son veston
et en maudit qu'il s'agissait de
l'épinglette de la dictée pgl j'ai su
que c'est sa petite fille caroline
bonjour qui a insisté
quelle belle idée que c'était un glas de
swala donc éducation relations
internationales aide au développement
son empreinte est à la fois diffuse
profonde et un délibéré je garderai en
mémoire sa participation à des
événements publics où malgré son très
grand âge sa fragilité physique évidente
il intervenait avec force éloquent sur
la question de l'éducation est la raison
d'être de nos institutions publiques
quel contraste entre l'image de cet
homme très âgé recroquevillait ce qui
reprend que de veiller sur son fauteuil
et la clarté de l'intellect rendu encore
plus évidente par la force du propos est
bien sûr tout cela dans une langue de
grande qualité
pas un accord qui cloche pas une liaison
qui manque est toujours le mot juste
je sais qu'en voyant et qu'en entendant
cet homme remarquable
beaucoup se sont dit il a raison il a
raison il faut rester fidèle aux grands
principes fondateurs qui ont guidé son
action
le québec de 2018 doit beaucoup à paul
gérin lajoie le québec de 2038 de 2058
de 2000 78 devra beaucoup à paul gérin
lajoie sa marque sur le québec est
permanente
il laisse dans le deuil outre sa famille
un peuple
reconnaissant à nous de préserver sa
mémoire et son héritage au nom de toutes
les québécoises et de tous les québécois
je dis à dieu et rend hommage à ce grand
partisan de la révolution tranquille qui
a ouvert au québec les portes de la
modernité
à nous de les ouvrir encore plus grave
et sous sa dictée bienveillante décrire
les prochaines pages de notre histoire
[Applaudissements]
nous allons maintenant entendre les
représentants de la famille de paul
gérin lajoie son fils aîné françois
accompagné d'alexis gérin lajoie et de
julie robert représentant les petits
enfants de paul gérin lajoie
merci monseigneur merci monsieur le
premier ministre pour l'organisation des
funérailles nationales de paul gérin
lajoie cher papin cher pga pour le fils
que je suis l'ayant accompagné pendant
plus de 50 ans l'émotion en la
circonstance et de la parole
il va de soi que l'accent porte
principalement sur ce papa que fut paul
gérin lajoie
cependant derrière notre papa il ya
l'homme public dont l'oeuvre
impressionnante des siens en héritage
transcende les générations depuis la
révolution tranquille sans rompre avec
l'émotion et la tristesse qui a bible et
qui habitent les membres de notre
famille je tenterai de résumer dans les
modestes phrase est mou qui suivent
quelques aspects de sa vie qui nous
paraissent martin l'éducation et à sa
préoccupation première
elle fut son oeuvre sa grande mission il
lui en a fallu de la fourguer des
convictions pour faire bouger les choses
et rallier à sa cause des éléments
conservateurs qui se posent à la grande
réforme du système scolaire
pensant ainsi nombre à bhl tournée à
travers les régions du québec pour
expliquer le v60
qui a mené à la création du conseil
supérieur de l'éducation et l'opération
55 qui a permis de réduire le nombre de
commissions scolaires nous avons nous
les enfants participer à ces tournées en
caravane
grâce à la dextérité légendaire de
pilotes de tong il pilote automobile de
momon papa lui avait un seul but en
appelle à la fin de ces journées est
exigeant il nous le disait son obsession
pour la scolarisation de la jeunesse le
souci de relever le niveau de vie des
québécois et la nécessité de projeter de
québec dans la modernité
pour y parvenir un aspect de sa
personnalité a joué en sa faveur son
irrépressible besoin d'inspirer pour
convainc il voulait obtenir la
nécessaire participation citoyenne sur
des enjeux importants de notre société
on doit le dire haut et fort il est un
des pans importants de l'histoire qui a
donné racines au québec entrepreneuriale
les années 80 le fameux québec inc
pendant ses discours à ceux ci est
toujours éducation économie
il reconnaîtra tard dans sa vie il a
sans doute hérité de ce bagage de
démocratie d'économie respectivement de
sa grand-mère marie-gérin-lajoie et de
son aïeul antoine j'avais ma joie la
création du ministère de l'éducation lui
a valu le titre de père de la réforme
scolaire sa volonté de changement s'est
manifesté avec courage devant l'église
conservatrice des années 60 sa volonté
de changement c'est ainsi manifesté avec
la même conviction face à l'état fédéral
la reconnaissance internationale du
québec dans ses champs de compétence
exclusive on a qualifié d'historique son
discours de 1965 prononcé devant le
corps consulaire à montréal pga l'état
lors des six premiers ministres son
plaidoyer au nom du gouvernement sur le
prolongement international des
compétences internes du québec fera des
vagues
pourtant la doctrine gérin-lajoie qu'il
est encore aujourd'hui la politique
internationale du québec
papa je le pense profondément
c'est un politique un politique au sens
noble du mot en raison de son engagement
profond dans la vie publique pour servir
la nation québécoise aussi parce qu'il
était un penseur non démagogique qui a
su attirer et rassemblés par ses idées
papa était exigeant et un redoutable
plaideur passionné engagé
c'est ainsi que s'est rassis de destin
d'un homme hors du commun un papa dont
moi mes soeurs et frères sommes
tellement fiers
nous avons tellement intrigant citoyens
moment de re voilà auprès d'elle c'est
merveilleux papa s'intéresse à tout
rédacteur éditorialiste du journal de
brébeuf photographes amateurs
collectionneurs à outrance timbres et
monnaies pour apprendre la géographie
l'histoire élevage de goupil et gardien
vue de la pouponnière papillons et
insectes pour apprendre la biologie et
magiciens à ses heures pour se détendre
et oui papa malgré tout son travail
savourer la vie à pleine dent de lait
puis mais beaucoup grâce à sa complice
maman maman disait tout pour lui et lui
résumait bibliographie anthologique
profit de presse et maman ça va y mettre
du piquant et du vivant pour s'assurer
que p&g elle retenait tour elle était
ans à son entraîneur intellectuelle
homme d'action poursuivant ses passions
et ses rêves papa avait toujours dans sa
poche de veston gauche côté gauche
multicoeurs un bout de papier sur lequel
il était inscrit le dicton et she can
dream up you can do et encore il avait
le champ libre car maman gérait tout ou
concernant la vie de famille maisonnée
finances transport des enfants incluant
évidemment
évidemment les repas de ses
collaborateurs travaillant sans arrêt
les week-ends les membres de la famille
élargie gérin lajoie nous rappeler à son
décès les fêtes de noël à dorion
lesquels s'étirait entre 10 heures et 4
heures du matin la messe était célébrée
par oncle andré un jésuite que des bons
moments en famille
papa vénéré l'esprit de famille papa fut
un homme d'action
un ardent travaillant un batteur nous
pouvons le dire sept jours sur scène un
oiseau de nuit
il écrivait ses textes et discours entre
11h et 3 4 heures du matin par être
d'ailleurs ces jours ci l'anthologie de
ses meilleurs discours
à 50 ans le voilà propulsé sur la scène
internationale le premier ministre
pierre elliott trudeau le nomme à
l'appel de l'agencé canadienne de
développement international afdi il aura
fait en huit ans le service l'équivalent
de 25 fois le tour du monde ces hauts
fonctionnaires exténué aurait déclaré
maintes fois doux seigneur doux seigneur
des livres et des livres et nous des
idées de p g l
un fait marquant il a accentué les
efforts du canada se rapprocher du 0,17
de 1% du produit intérieur brut du
canada a consacré de la coopération
internationale telle que souhaitée par
les studios personnes prix nobel de la
paix et ancien premier ministre du
canada ou si votre père sur premier
ministre hulot avait au préalable
nommé papa à titre de vice-président de
la commission détruire venu afin de
juguler l'inflation
tgl s'y ranger il s'est repris par la
suite
alec dit en faisant tripler le budget de
l'aide petite anecdote vous croyez que
nos expériences en caravanes se sont
arrêtées avec l'opération 55 eh bien non
à peine nommé président de l'acdi et gl
décisive
pour ces petites vacances à l'été 70
cette fois ci en europe avec citroën et
boulotte la mène tous les enfants pour
des rencontres
il emmène tous les enfants excusez moi
sans nous dire bien évidemment qu'il
fera quelques rencontres
quelques arrêts protocolaire j'ai 19 ans
avec mon copilote bernard et sylvie je
dois me taper l'arc de triomphe en
roulotte et une semaine plus tard c'est
milan stationnés en double devant la
coupe du gouvernorat
pendant deux heures les claques sion les
klaxons des fiat italienne résonne
toujours à nos oreilles
et que dire de sa cinquième et dernière
carrière grand bénévole devant l'éternel
il démarre la fondation pgl à l'âge de
67 ans c'est mon âge aujourd'hui
imaginer une carrière autonome au niveau
international
affectueusement nos amis africains nomme
sagement le nouveau venu de vieux débute
alors une aventure passionnante au pga
le missionnaire
il reprend sur le continent africain son
combat de l'éducation de
l'alphabétisation pour tous sammis sa
mission débute au pays de la téranga
sénégal avec son allié et partenaire
indéfectible
abdou diouf alors premier ministre de la
république du sénégal
papa un humaniste qui voulait changer le
monde la dictée pgl être une autre
exemple illustrant le génie de papa au
début
au début ou 90 au moment où la dictée
pivot fait fureur en europe et en
amérique
pascal lefrançois venait tout juste à
l'âge de 17 ans de faire bonne figure et
voilà que papa me dis pourquoi pas une
dictée pro fondation paul gérin-lajoie
afin d'intéresser des jeunes écoliers à
la coopération internationale
papa est très friand de citations et de
slogans portant à la réflexion et à
l'action
rappelons-nous l'est m chili qui
s'instruit s'enrichit fin d'école soif
d'apprendre
nous cherchons tous les 2e titre punch
et pour la dictée pgl trouvait trop
prétentieux la déclinaison la dictée
paul gérin lajoie ou trop long la dictée
de la fondation paul gérin lajoie
je lui ai rappelé que de toute façon il
préférait que ses collaborateurs
l'interpellent par ses initiales oui
celle de p g l tout simplement
évidemment toujours dans le but
d'accélérer les choses
c'est ainsi que la dictée pgl est né sur
le sol sous le slogan écrire un monde
meilleur
trois mois plus tard 400 écoles des cent
mille élèves sont inscrits l'année
suivant sous la thématique ma planète
vue d'en haut on est propulsé d'un
nouveau sommet et on double la cadence
devinez qui est notre porte parole et
oui une astronaute
merci madame examen général ni pga les
mois ne pouvions alors soutenu imaginer
les mêmes rêver que 27 ans plus tard il
y aurait plus de 7 millions cinq cent
mille élèves sur deux continents
adjacent l'océan atlantique amérique du
nord et afrique
rivalisant entre eux de façon solidaire
et engagé dans la poursuite d'un idéal
imaginé par papa de prix sans fondateur
grégory charles aime bien me le rappeler
plus d'acronymes ont la cote et la
notoriété de puget halle au québec la
francophonie même en 1960 alors ministre
de la jeunesse
il assiste comme représentants d'états à
la création d'ac on fait même réunissant
les ministres de l'éducation de la
francophonie à ce titre il prend place
parmi les grands senghor bourguiba diori
ici à nous en sommes il est de ceux qui
font la promotion de l'événement de la
coopération francophone dans le monde il
est aux côtés de l'institution naissance
alors qu'elle faisait ses premiers pas
plus tard l'agencé de coopération
culturelle et technique la société créée
avec à sa tête le québécois il regretté
jean marc léger qui en sera le premier
secrétaire général pg elle est alors
prise en bac 10 est très fier d'être
présent à niamey ce 20 mars 1970 il
était témoin d'un événement hautement
symbolique pour l'avenir de la
francophonie de jean louis roy à son
excellence madame michaëlle jean
la fondation paul gérin-lajoie [ __ ]
fier partenaire de l'organisation
internationale de la francophonie
nous sommes heureux de poursuivre notre
mission éducative auprès des jeunes
grâce à de multiples programmes et
projets de louis ix est un merci
particulier à madame le secrétaire
général de l'unef qui nous aura permis
d'innover avec la première dictée pgl
grand public en ligne en direct grâce à
la magie du web et la participation de
tv5 effective pour mon père n'a pas
seulement pour les garçons les filles
mais aussi pour les femmes et les jeunes
filles n'avaient aucune chance
d'apprendre les enfants de la rue des
orphelins les grands parents des grands
parents qu'elle a besoin d'apprendre à
lire et écrire
donc il était question également
d'inclure les enfants aux besoins
particuliers
mon frère est venu d'une famille qui
s'est battu pour les droits de ces
villes et la démocratie
cette famille
qui lui a donné des occasions des
perspectives 2002 venir il a permis de
rêver toute sa vie il a pensé à ce qui
ne l'est pas c'est le perspectives
d'avenir tout commence à québec avec ces
joutes dessus jaune qui était partout et
s'assurant que chaque enfant puisse
aller à l'école jusqu'à 16 ans son legs
important l'éducation des sommets
inégalés jusqu'à la révolution
tranquille d'héritage de p&g elle est
considérée combien d'entre vous ici
présents dans la cathédrale devez votre
carrière à paul gérin lajoie le nombre
de témoignages reçus à cet effet dépasse
l'imagination
je me rappelle le dernier voyage de bgl
en ambulance alors que l'anglais aussi
c'est ce qu'a mon époux stinat ma
carrière de 38 ans je la dois votre père
et votre beau-père et je lui en serai
éternellement reconnaissant mon ami et
partenaire de la coopération de l'hyper
dit andrée beaudoin proclame haut et
fort que la révolution tranquille a
complètement changé la vocation est
transformé le métier d'agriculteur
et que dire de ce témoignage qui leur a
sans doute sourire les premiers
ministres du québec d'un confident
exceptionnelle de la scène politique
québécoise et internationale et fervent
admirateur de p g l john parisella a
souvent répété
ton père françois
a été le premier il a été le meilleur
premier ministre du québec que l'on a
jamais eu
papa paul gérin lajoie n'est plus mais
son oeuvre pérenne traverse le temps pg
elle transcende les générations les
étiquettes des logiques les chapelles et
les partis politiques
le géant québécois qu'il est devenu à
partie à la nation tout entière
le moment est venu de te dire adieu cher
papa tu vas beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
nous manquer c'est déjà le cas dominique
et jacques sylvie d'honorer des nues
tina et moi sommes désormais par foehn
et mettons armed à pauvres dont l'esprit
lumineux et ton humanisme évolutionniste
nous habite
il nous éviterons toujours et si qu'au
cours des années futures
pas seulement celle de la famille et de
tous ces québécois de tous et
québécoises et québécois qui t'ont
désigné dans leurs loges ce mois dernier
comme père de la révolution tranquille
de la doctrine gérin-lajoie de
l'éducation gratuite de la dictée pgl et
sans oublier évidemment la fondation
paul gérin lajoie et des nombreuses
écoles qui porte fièrement ton nom et
j'aimerais mentionné en particulier la
cité des gens de vaudreuil vives et gm
et que continue de vivre la révolution
tranquille vive l'éducation pour tous et
de qualité pape a remercié éternellement
pour tous ces apprentissages que tous
les abonnés et pour ton amour infini
je t'aime je t'aime on nous t'aimerons
pour toujours oups je l'oublié côté
gauche
kodikara dernier message de piger elle
avoue les jeunes prière prière de rêver
avec nous les vieux message
selon l'adage afrique et rêvons ensemble
à un monde meilleur
notre planète on a bien besoin
merci de votre attention et je passe la
parole à la prochaine génération
[Applaudissements]
comme vous pouvez le deviner
nous les petits enfants avons connu paul
gérin lajoie sous un angle complètement
différent pour nous il était seulement
grand papa paul nous aurions été curieux
de connaître l'adolescent ambitieux qui
a convaincu un jury principalement
anglophone de lui octroyer la bourse
roads alors qu'il ne parlait pas anglais
ou le nouveau diplômé d'oxford qui
revenait au québec
à 28 ans pour faire sa marque ou celui
dans la trentaine qui s'engager en
politique active pour moderniser le
québec
nous n'avons également pas connu le
ministre dans la quarantaine persévérant
et déterminé convaincu que l'éducation
demeure l'outil essentiel au
développement personnel et collectif
ni le président de l'agglo dans la
cinquantaine engagé 2d en engagés à
développer des projets porteurs chez nos
partenaires africains et d'ailleurs nous
avons connu un paul gérin lajoie plus
âgés certes mais toujours avec une
énergie surprenante une indéfectible
volonté de changer les choses est de
rester pertinent grand papa
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir pu observer
alors que tu donnais des discours dans
les dernières années et j'étais
tellement fière de toi à chaque fois je
te trouvais tellement inspirant malgré
tes 93 ans tu n'aurais raté pour rien au
monde
mon assermentation barreaux enfin une
descendante accéder à la profession de
ton père et de son grand-père et pendant
un instant elite j'étais la plus jeune
membre du barreau il lui un des pilotes
les plus anciens nous nous souvenons de
toi grand papa lors des réunions de
famille tu suivais nous discutions avec
des yeux rieurs et avec ton sourire
tendre toujours curieux et avec un mot à
dire sur chaque sujet nous nous
souvenons de ton calme et de ta patience
avec nous nicolas et frédéric pouvait
jouer au mini hockey pendant des heures
juste au dessus de ton bureau où tu
recevais des collaborateurs et jamais on
leur a demandé de faire moins de bruit
ou d'arrêter de jouer
nous avons connu en tant que mari
attentionné qui a pris soin avec
tendresse de grand-maman dre grand papa
je sais que tu ne seras plus là
physiquement avec nous mais ce sera avec
nous le jour où mon fils michael il râle
écoles la première fois et lorsqu'il
fera sa première dictée pgl tu nous a
montré que la vie mérite amplement
d'être vécue tu nous a montré que si on
mettait toute notre énergie et notre
passion on pouvait réellement faire une
différence et accomplir de grandes
choses
je sais que pour toi
ta mission n'était jamais vraiment
accompli mais tu peux te reposer
maintenant on va s'occuper du reste
merci
[Applaudissements]
mon cousin alexis va dire quelques mots
maintenant merci jean
ça m'embête je suis un peu nerveux mais
quand même fort de mon grand-père était
une personne un homme merveilleux et
héros pour moi & watch et oued
maniche or il me disait souvent des
histoires magnifiques
il m'a appris beaucoup de choses
attendez je vais recommencer
aux riceys je lui disais toujours grand
papa tu cries avec moi pour tout allié
c'était vrai je t'aime grand papa et oui
tu seras toujours dans ma vie merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
le prochain témoignage sera celui d'un
ministre actuellement responsable de
l'éducation
monsieur sébastien proulx ministre de
l'éducation du loisir et du sport et
madame hélène david ministre responsable
de l'enseignement supérieur mais d'abord
nous entendrons le témoignage de
monsieur mamane ou d'oreilles
ex-ministre de l'éducation et du sénégal
et membre honoraire du conseil
d'administration de la fondation paul
gérin lajoie
si le premier ministre
sheikh membre de la famille j'ai roulé
tout d'abord dire que paul gérin lajoie
avait aussi une famille au sénégal et en
afrique
pour moi il était un père spirituel en
compagnons de combat pour l'éducation
est un âne
[Musique]
il a joué pour moi un modèle de robe
pour gérer la joie était un idéaliste
humaniste mais qui tenait
à mettre à l'épreuve ses idées
généreuses dans le laboratoire de la vie
avec et pour les autres les actes qu'il
a ainsi posé ont laissé une empreinte
indélébile dans l'histoire du québec
je tiens pour ma part a évoqué une autre
facette de cet homme multidimensionnel
qui est qui témoignent
de l'exemplarité d'une citoyenneté -
galles consciente des actifs
loin des pères du québec à salut du
sénégal il se trouve à face aux enfants
sans école et il n'a plus cible pour lui
il décida de s'engager pour offrir une
éducation à ses enfants
pourtant il mesure est parfaitement
l'ampleur du phénomène donc de la tâche
tout comme ils situer les
responsabilités en cause dans son
approche du généreuse mais pragmatique
il se disait que chacun prenne sa part
moi je subirai pleinement la mienne
c'est ainsi
que pris un envol qui va marquer
l'histoire de l'éducation en afrique son
engagement en faveur de l'éducation pour
tous avec un credo faire toujours plus
toujours mieux et autrement c'est-à-dire
innover un effet au delà des enfants
sans école or l'âge paul gérin lajoie
est andy son action aux autres laissés
pour compte du système éducatif
les jeunes et les adultes analphabètes
parmi ses projets phares
l'alphabétisation professionnalisantes
des femmes
la formation insertion des jeunes pour
gérin lajoie avait tout compris que
l'exercice du droit à l'éducation ne
pouvait pas ici se limiter à
l'acquisition des instruments de base de
l'apprentissage
c'est à dire la littératie et la
numération il fallait
en plus équiper ses des menus en
compétences de vie et de travail afin
qu'ils puissent construire le port
autonome y accéder à un emploi décent et
s'intégrer dans la société à cette
action sur le terrain pour gérin lajoie
a lié un plaidoyer intense au plan
international se dire que des milliers
d'enfants de jeunes d'adultes de filles
des garçons d'hommes et de femmes lui
sont éternellement reconnaissants de
l'avoir ouverte la porte à l'éducation
du sénégal du mali de haïti du niger du
bénin du burkina faso
les messages de ses diminue est toujours
le même paul gérin lajoie
tu peux reposer en paix en tant que
citoyen mondial qui a rempli pleinement
ton de voix et tu as réussi à ce que
d'autres êtres humains pour et diminue
accède à la dignité humaine oui paul
gérin lajoie
[Musique]
j'entends sa voix elle me dit mamadou tu
me prenait assez pour savoir que je ne
serai pas tranquille
simon 9 ne me survit pas ne se développe
pas et ne réalisent pas nos objectifs
d'éducation pour tous c'est de la
fondation
mesdames messieurs les messages et
transmis contribuer à la continuité de
l'oeuvre de paul gérin lajoie
[Musique]
c'est le meilleur hommage aux smart m
campus lui offrir je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
bonjour il y a des moments qui marquent
à jamais l'histoire il y a des journées
que l'on n'oublie pas les journées qui
témoigne de nos accomplissements
collectif mais aussi celle où l'on
célèbre les hommes et les femmes qui ont
façonné et on fait évoluer notre société
aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans ces moments
qui nous amène à nous rappeler et à
célébrer un géant de la société
québécoise un homme que j'ai toujours
appelé monsieur le ministre
lorsque j'ai eu le privilège d'échanger
avec lui en public ou en privé un géant
pgl trois lettres connues de tous
une ministre c'est à mon tour de vous
rendre hommage de vous exprimer au nom
de nos concitoyens notre gratitude
collective
il s'appelle lise pierre anne marie
martin félip ou julie ils savent que
vous leur avez donné accès à l'éducation
il s'appelle isabelle martin sébastien
ou victoire et ils savent que si ils
peuvent rêver à des études
universitaires techno professionnel
c'est aussi grâce à vous aujourd'hui
c'est près de trois générations de
québécois qui peuvent être maîtres de
leur destin éducatif et contribuer à
l'avenir du québec
grâce à vous et elles sont avec nous
aujourd'hui c'est génération auprès de
vos proches pour témoigner de notre
reconnaissance
parce que vous saviez depuis toujours
que l'épanouissement de la société
québécoise passerait par l'éducation
parce que vous saviez depuis toujours
que les québécois avaient besoin de
l'éducation pour s'émanciper prospérer
devenir libres et prendre leur place ici
si et ailleurs vous avez fait plus que
tous ces artisans de la révolution
tranquille qui pourtant en ont fait
beaucoup
vous avez fait plus que tous ses
ministres de l'éducation qui n'ont
jamais oublier que vous fûtes le premier
qui n'ont jamais oublier que vous avez
ouvert la voie défricher ce mais je ne
les jamais oublier à chaque jour où
j'exerce ce privilège immense de mener à
bien votre grande mission éducative est
votre longue vie vous aura permis de
contempler une partie de la récolte
vous avez fait l'éducation au québec
vous avez contribué à faire ce qu'est le
québec aujourd'hui et jusqu'à la fin
vous avez appelé à une mobilisation
générale en faveur de l'éducation mais
votre humilité s'est toujours refusé à
reconnaître l'importance de votre l'aide
jamais vous ne vous êtes satisfait de ce
que vous nous aviez déjà laissé toujours
il vous fallait continuer à agir à
travailler vous avez fait don à
l'éducation au québec de votre personne
un donc sans jamais rien demander en
retour pour vous l'éducation c'était la
liberté pour les individus pour le
québec pour chaque peuple de la planète
ce que vous étiez pas pensé votre vision
votre engagement nous le devons
collectivement et nous devons
collectivement nous engager à les
préserver
comme un gage ou un serment à redire
pour chaque génération il et
marie-laurence les aimants des thomas où
mes enfants
marie rose et nicolas apprendront
bientôt qu'ils vous sont redevables
ils ne le savent pas encore nous allons
leur apprendre
monsieur le ministre cher paul gérin
lajoie se sont toutes les écoles du
québec qui à travers moi vous salue et
s'incline devant vous aujourd'hui ce
sont tous les élèves les enseignants les
personnel de soutien les commissaires et
cadre scolaire et les parents qui vous
disent merci aux membres de votre
famille à vos enfants et petits enfants
mes plus sincères condoléances
je ne peux malheureusement partager la
tristesse intime qui vous habite en ce
moment mais nous sommes des millions à
partager une immense fierté et avoir
célébré l'héritage de celui qui
demeurera toujours à mes yeux
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
merci
[Applaudissements]
les émotions se bousculent en cette
journée où le québec tout entier se
réunit pour honorer la mémoire de paul
gérin lajoie le chagrin collectif
entourant son décès ne saurait être
éclipsé que par le devoir de célébrer la
vie l'oeuvre et le legs de ce monument
de l'histoire du québec
le dernier demi siècle aura été marquée
par des changements profonds et durables
qui ont transformé à jamais nos valeurs
et nos repères collectifs
la révolution des années 60 bien qu'elle
fut qualifié de tranquille n'en fut pas
moins une véritable révolution et elle
porte
indubitablement la signature distinctive
de paul gérin lajoie premier ministre de
l'éducation du québec vice premier
ministre à l'origine du réseau des
cégeps et de celui de l'université du
québec grand philanthrope il aura été
d'abord et avant tout un grand humaniste
et un grand grand démocrate
un grand homme paul gérin lajoie a eu
l'audace de transformer les orientations
du rapport parent en institution non
seulement de brique et de mortier mais
aussi et avant tout en lieu de culture
et de savoir
il se sera consacrée campréal à la
promotion de l'éducation et de
l'enseignement supérieur
à une époque où la moitié des québécois
adultes n'avait complété qu'une sixième
année d'instruction
il aura eu le courage d'affirmer que
l'université n'a de compte à rendre qu'à
la vérité il aura eu l'esprit
visionnaire pour porter à bout de bras
et parfois envers et contre tous le
projet de toute une société
à titre de ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur est accompagné par toutes les
communautés collégiales et
universitaires
c'est avec le plus grand respect et la
plus grande humilité que nous devons
suivre les traces de ce bâtisseur et de
ce père du québec moderne
de rouyn noranda rimouski de gatineau
aux îles de la madeleine les réseaux des
universités et des cégeps brille comme
autant de flambeau projetant la vision
de cet homme plus grand que nature
des milliers de jeunes des quatre coins
du québec et de par le monde fréquente
dorénavant un système éducatif que paul
gérin lajoie a contribué à créer à
moderniser et à démocratiser pour que
chacun et chacune puisse aller au bout
de ses rêves
sa conviction profonde selon laquelle
les origines de nady vie du ne devrait
jamais jamais limité son univers des
possibles figurent désormais au panthéon
des valeurs québécoises
aujourd'hui je tenais à transmettre mes
plus sincères condoléances à la famille
et aux proches de monsieur gérin lajoie
mais également à l'ensemble des
québécoises et des québécois qui ont
perdu le 25 juin dernier un modèle et
une boussole collective bien que paul
gérin lajoie nous ait quittés ses idéaux
et son remarquable travail seront
inscrit à jamais parmi les plus grandes
réussites de la société québécoise à
françois son fils avec qui j'ai
travaillé et à la famille
je tiens à souligner à nouveau l'immense
privilège d'avoir eu ton père comme
guide rassurant et exigent des destinées
de l'enseignement supérieur au québec
merci pgl comme nous vous avons toujours
à clé avec affection
le québec devra s'habituer à être
orphelin de votre pensée et de votre
présence vous nous manquez déjà avant de
vous laisser entamer cet ultime voyage
permettez-moi de revenir une dernière
fois sur ces paroles que vous avez
prononcé encore tout récemment
l'éducation publique doit demeurer et
doit devenir davantage à tous les jours
la priorité de tous les québécois
priorité de leur gouvernement
ma priorité de leurs institutions
locales priorité de tous
en définitive pour faire en sorte que ce
système d'éducation réussisse son grand
objectif son objectif permanent celui
d'assurer la réussite de chacun de nos
enfants québécois
vous avez été paul gérin lajoie un
modèle d'engagement politique
authentique incarné est déterminé à
l'aube de l'exercice démocratique qui
nous attend et auquel vous avez toujours
cru profondément à nous de faire honneur
à vos exigences et à votre éthique et à
proposer à nos concitoyens et
concitoyennes un projet de société à la
hauteur des aspirations que vous avez
toujours porter pour le québec tant ici
qu'à l'international notre planète notre
pays et notre province ont plus que
jamais besoin de paul gérin lajoie
soyons dignes de sa mémoire merci
[Applaudissements]
un dernier mot monsieur dany laferrière
qui est aussi non seulement ami de la
famille
mais l'ami académiciens de la famille
dallaire avant que les hommages
funérailles officielles de prévient la
voix la joie des buts et j'étais assis
là et beaucoup de gens venaient me
parler et d'autres parlaient entre eux
ils racontaient paul gérin lajoie
au fil des minutes j'ai même
l'impression que cet homme était en
train de devenir immédiatement sous nos
yeux éblouis
un récit collectif c'est très rapide il
y a des livres qui deviennent classique
avant même que l'encré ne sèchent
immédiatement pourquoi parce que sa vie
exemplaire
l'inspiration qu'il a su distiller dans
la population s'est changé en anecdotes
lumineuse rutilantes les gens étaient
contents d'être contents ils étaient
contents de ce plaisir de raconter une
bonne histoire
la vie de paul gérin lajoie les
anecdotes qu'ils ont ramassé par ce pas
là et quelque chose de plus profond ce
qu'il a fait profondément littéralement
faire de l'école
la nouvelle chose importante du québec
j'ai rencontré une fois longuement paul
gérin lajoie avec jean françois lisée
qui avait organisé cette empreinte
croisés et était assis à côté de lui et
je lui racontais un peu l'image qu'ils
avaient du québec en arrivant je lui
disais que je n'étais pas trop d'accord
avec l'idée de la grande noirceur qui
donne l impression que le québec était
en noir et blanc la couleur n'étaient
pas encore arrivés avant la révolution
tranquille alors que c'était des jeunes
gens comme lui qui ont provoqué lumineux
et la guerre qui ont provoqué cela et
qu'à cette révolution tranquille il
fallait imaginer rené lévesque et robert
bourassa chacun projecteurs en mai et
immédiatement ploguer si l'on peut dire
à la baie james
pour éclairer le québec et je vois et
ses yeux d'enfant qui me regarde et il
ne m'a pas corrigé lui qui a connu cette
époque et j'ai compris pourquoi
autre jeu de la joie elle est restée
dans la mémoire des gens c'est sûr
regard d'enfant ce qu'il a aimé dans
tout cela c'est le fait que je parlais
de ce que je ne savais pas et se fait
pas ça s'appelle la fente hills
quand vous laisse lui un peuple il faut
être efficace il faut vraiment avoir une
raison de le faire
des arguments pour le faire mais avoir
autour de vous aussi un ensemble de gens
prêts à le faire une mécanique et tout
ce que vous avez besoin pour continuer à
vivre de cet oxygène de l'esprit c'est
la fantaisie tout à l'heure un de ses
petits-enfants
cette jeune fille a raconté qu'il
n'était pas du tout gênée par le bruit
que faisait les enfants du joueur au
dessus
cette fantaisie de ces gens qui
détestent mourir dans le silence il
préfère le bruit et la chanson des
enfants c'est cette fantaisie qui après
c'était dit retraite la mer s'enfoncer
dans le monde dans les gens à devenir
quelqu'un simplement un quidam qui
pouvaient au nom de l'éducation partir
en afrique dans les différents pays
on a cité tout à l'heure en haïti et
continuer ce travail qui rassemble tout
le monde puisque l'un des vieux raison
du québec cdccq vire tout le monde
ce n'est pas comme probation pas du tout
c'est simplement l'éducation est ainsi
fait que vous ne pouvez pas l'avoir tout
seul elle n'a de sens que si l'autre est
aussi instruit c'est simplement vous
cela
et à ce niveau je voulais simplement
pour un petit temps pour dire qu est-ce
qui fait quelqu'un comme paul gérin
lajoie
qu'est ce qui fait que immédiatement il
soit devenu un classique
si l'on peut dire c'est parce que rien
n'est plus facile
que d'être paul gérin lajoie il suffit
d'aimer
là ça devient plus difficile
ça m'a rappelé d'ailleurs monica vitti à
qui un journaliste avait demandé mais
vous êtes tellement belle tellement
brillante tellement je donnerai ma vie
vaut aimer boîte email vous l'a dit
c'est facile de m'avoir il suffit de
memis vraiment c'est vraiment les
problèmes et c'est vraiment qui va être
un peu le grand producteur de la vie de
paul gérin lajoie
c'est à dire à partir du moment où on
est plus dans un devoir simple devoir
on est dans l'amour des gens eh bien on
se nourrit même de cet amour on parle
beaucoup du projet l'a rejoint en
afrique c'est mamadou à thème très bien
expliqué il en a été le porte-voix
j'allais dire le griot même de cela mais
ce qu'on oublie de dire c'est tout ce
qu'il a appris de cette énergie de
l'énergie de ces affamés d'alpha b et c
où cela simplement je dis qu'aujourd'hui
paul gérin lajoie est mort mais 26
mètres d'alphabet pétillante tout plein
de joie d'énergie et de gaieté le salut
est éclair sont semaine vers
l'immortalité
[Applaudissements]
je remercie vivement toutes les
personnes qui ont exprimé leurs
témoignages et qui nous rappelle que
nous sommes justement réunis par paul
gérin lajoie aujourd'hui c'est lui qui
nous rassemble je réitère mes
salutations madame la mairesse de
montréal vers des plantes
on sait pourquoi
chers amis tournons nous vers le christ
avec confiance en reconnaissant que nous
sommes pêcheurs et ouvrons nos coeurs à
la miséricorde de dieu
[Musique]
oh
à
et
oh
ça nous fasse miséricorde qu'il nous
pardonne nos péchés nous conduisait la
vie éternelle
lyon le seigneur seigneur nous sommes
dans la peine nous te confions le paul
notre frère afin que tu l'accueil dans
ta miséricorde infinie
toi qui es vivant pour les siècles des
siècles amen
lecture de l'apocalypse de saint jean
moi j'en j'ai vu un ciel nouveau est une
terre nouvelle car le premier ciel est
la première terre s'en est allé et de
mer il n'y en a plus et la ville c'est
de la jérusalem nouvelle je l' ai vu qui
descendait du ciel d'eau près de dieu
traite pour les noces comme une épouse
paré pour son ma vie et j'entendis une
voix forte qui venait du trône
elle disait voici la demeure de dieu
avec les hommes
il demeurera avec eux et ils seront ces
peuples et lui même jeu avec eux sera
leur dieu il essuiera toute larme de
leurs yeux et la mort ne sera plus et il
n'y aura plus ni deuil ni écrit ni
douleur ce qui était en premier s'en est
allé alors celui qui siégeait sur le
trône déclara voici que je fais toutes
choses nouvelles
moi je suis l'alpha et l'oméga le
commencement et la fin à celui qui a
soif
moi je donnerai l'eau de la source de
vie gratuitement
tel sera l'héritage du vainqueur
je serai son dieu et lui sera monfils
parole du seigneur
est ce suffisant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces contrats justice et outre les arènes
sont affinés [ __ ]
entre jugement avec un serviteur mon
avis on est justement 3
[Musique]
ma
je me souviens des jours d'autres voies
je me reding des actions sur l'oeuvre de
tes mains je vais team jeu tandem avec
toi voici deux ans
c'est
[Musique]
on souffle mais sans khimki dans le pays
de l'est pour l'honneur de ces mois ci à
trausse de la justice titre
[Musique]
je
lecture de la première lettre de saint
jean mais bien aimé nous savons que nous
sommes passés de la mort à la vie parce
que nous aimons nos frères celui qui
n'aime pas demeure dans la mort voici
comment nous avons reconnu l'amour lui
jésus a donné sa vie pour nous nous
aussi nous devons donner notre vie pour
nos frères celui qui a de quoi vivre en
ce monde s'il voit son frère dans le
besoin sans faire preuve de compassion
comme l'amour de dieu pourra-t-il
demeurer en lui petits enfants n'aimant
pas en paroles ni par des discours mais
par des actes et en vérité voilà comment
nous reconnaîtrons que nous appartenons
à la vérité et de vente yeux nous
appellerons notre coeur
car si notre coeur nous a cure dieu est
plus grand que notre coeur et il connaît
toutes choses parole du seigneur
[Applaudissements]
on
oh
[Musique]
celui qui croît de 6,3 et moi
je leur ai suscite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour
[Musique]
le seigneur soit avec vous et venger le
de jésus-christ selon saint jean
ainsi parla jésus puis il leva les yeux
au ciel et 10 pers
l'heure est venue glorifie en fait ça
fait que le fils de l'orifice ainsi
qu'en qui lui a donné pouvoir sur tout
être de chair
il donnera la vie éternelle à tout ce
que tu lui as donné aux la vie éternelle
c'est qu'ils te connaissent toi le seul
vrai dieu et celui que tu as envoyé
jésus-christ père ce que tu m'as donné
tu veux que là je suis ils soient eux
aussi avec moi et qu'il contemple
magloire celle que tu m'as donné parce
que tu m'as aimé avant la fondation du
monde perd juste le monde ne t'a pas
connue mais moi je t'ai connu et ceux ci
ont reconnu que tu m'en voyez je leur ai
fait connaître ton nom et je le ferai
connaître pour que l'amour dont tu m'a
aimée soit en eux et que moi aussi je
sois en eux acclamant la parole de dieu
chères familles le paul gérin lajoie
déjà lorsque nos parents sont avec nous
toujours avec nous on sait qu'il nous
habite
mais de façon un peu étonnante et
mystérieuse
c'est après leur départ on prend un peu
plus conscience jusqu'à quel point il
nous habite
je remercie tous ceux et celles qui ont
donné des témoignages et qu'ils ont
exprimées ici je pense des mots clés
c'est le mot et héritage tout ce qu'ils
ont reçu dans la famille dans la société
à la paroisse sainte trinité envers 16
de valleyfield au à gérer la joie allait
souvent à l'occasion de son décès les
les paroissiens et paroissiennes parlait
encore de lui avec affection dans le mou
et laitages
qu'est ce qui fait que quelqu'un peut
transmettre un héritage
parce qu'on peut vivre et à quel degré
est ce qu'on transmet une d'héritage par
notre vie si on
on se l'est fait à saint paul dont pas
le général j'avais le poney saisir le
prénom si on se réfère à saint paul une
expression de sympa c'est que tout don
et pour un service et je pense que c'est
une des clés de la transmission d'un
héritage c'est de voir les dons que l'on
a reçu comme un appel à servir de ne pas
les garder pour soi seul pour profiter
de la vie mais de les voir comme un
appel à servir pour le le monde meilleur
en asie pour le bien de la communauté
bien sûr ça prend une cause aussi on
veut servir une cause on veut servir un
peuple on veut servir la planète dont
veut servir le monde avec une cause et
les dernières décennies pour ainsi dire
de ne pas gérer la joie sont comme une
synthèse de tout ce qui a précédé une
éducation de qualité pour tous ici comme
ailleurs avec un sens de solidarité
internationale est sensible à tout ce
qui est humain sur la planète et croire
à l'importance d'une éducation de
qualité
on peut discuter sur le contenu
d'éducation de qualité mais viser une
éducation de qualité
c'est comme un appel fondamental et je
crois que dans cette idée à cette cause
qui habitait profonde et mal le coeur de
paul notre frère paul
je crois qu'un peuple tout entier sur le
trouvère et qu'il était comme rarement
quelqu'un remporté un idéal en étant
seul
dans le sens ce qui fait qu'un idéal
porte c'est qu'il est l'expression de ce
qui est déjà portée par un peuple et
c'était la soif
c'était la soif qui habitait les coeurs
d'un peuple du peuple québécois héritage
donc tout donner pour un service en même
temps nous qui voulons aussi transmettre
un héritage
est-ce qu'on peut transmettre un
héritage dans nos vies sans avoir reçu
100 voire de succion peut transmettre si
on peut transmettre un héritage si on
peut mettre au service d'une cause noble
et généreuse
tous nos dons c'est que justement on a
reçu on a besoin d'avoir reçu ce qui
renvoie à une autre phrase de saint paul
4 su que tu n'as pas reçu avoir reçu ça
veut pas dire qu'on répète ce qu'on a
reçu ça peut avoir besoin d'être
renouvelées ça peut avoir besoin d'être
approfondis ça peut avoir besoin d'être
changés parfois dans certains aspects
mais y'a comme la reconnaissance qu'on a
reçu et peut-être que pour transmettre
un héritage s'apprend dans les deux cas
tu que tu n'as pas reçu mais en même
temps tout donner pour un service un
service d'une cause et dans la mesure où
il faut gérer la joie se présente à nous
comme une grande figure
peut-être qu'on pourrait se voir on
pourrait recevoir ici sa vie comme une
double question qu'est ce que j'ai reçu
et quelle est la cause que je veux
servir et dans ce sens là comme il peut
nous parler à chacun et chacune d'entre
nous et nous inviter à nous questionner
nous mêmes sur la trace que nous voulons
faire sur cette terre pour améliorer
faire grandir le monde dans lequel on
vit à travers tout le défi qu'il a
relevé
cet héritage que paul finalement que
l'héritage de la vie de paul qui prend
de multiples dimensions c'est un des
aspects nous renvoie aussi au fait que
nous tous nous sommes appelés à laisser
un héritage autant qu'à accueillir
l'héritage dans notre famille dans la
société lorsqu'on a la foi dans l'église
recevoir l'héritage au se donner pour
transmettre et faire grandir nous
l'envoie aussi au fait que dieu lui-même
nous donne un héritage en jésus qui
vient dans le monde vous révéler l'amour
de dieu ils viennent nous dans le monde
nous révéler que nous sommes les enfants
de dieu que nous sommes appelés avec les
enfants de dieu que le plan de dieu
c'est de faire de nous ses enfants pour
l'éternité et pour saisir les frères des
soeurs les uns des ordres pour
l'éternité
c'est un héritage qui ouvre de nouveaux
horizons sur non seulement sur cette vie
mais sur l'ampleur de la vie éternelle
en tout cas du moins il ya une soif
d'absolu et cette soif d'absolu trouve
un écho dans la vie éternelle qui nous
est annoncé par jésus-christ une soif
d'absolu c'est non seulement vivent
totalement mais c'est une aspiration
vouloir vivre tout le temps et le moment
de la mort que ce soit la perspective de
notre propre mort la perte d'un être
cher
c'est un moment où on peut se demander
qui est ce que la mort est le dernier
mot est ce que la mort le dernier mot
sur la vie est ce que la mort est le
dernier morceau nos projets est ce que
la mort est le dernier mot sur les liens
d'amour d'amitié qu'on a pu passer à
travers une vie jésus-christ vient
ouvrir notre esprit notre intelligence
notre coeur notre âme et nous appeler à
nous ouvrir la la grandeur de dieu qui
viennent nous dire la mort n'a pas le
dernier
ce qui a le dernier mot c'est l'amour de
dieu l'amour éternel de dieu jésus a
reçu comme héritage du même d'être le
fils du père et qu'est ce qu'il veut
nous transmettre en héritage
et bien c'est de faire de nous des
enfants du père éternel par sa grâce
c'est un héritage précieux parce que
pour différentes raisons mais sa vie
comme recueillir toute notre existence
notre existence personnelle notre
existence familiale notre existence
socialement mais tant que l'existence
même du monde
que ce soit pour nous mais pour notre
famille pour la société pour la planète
entière pour l'humanité la mort n'a pas
le dernier mot et la puissance de
jésus-christ qui a donné sa vie à la
mort pour nous mais qui aussi a
ressuscité c'est une puissance de vie
qui nous est donné dès maintenant à
travers la prière à travers la vie
spirituelle qui vient nous ouvrir nos
horizons pour nous rend capables
d'espérance quelle que soit l'ampleur
des défis à relever
on a parlé de
ne pas gérer la joie comme un homme de
persévérance
quand on persévère c'est parce qu'on
continue du pouvoir quels que soient les
obstacles
lorsque dans tout projet dans ton rêve
s'ils ont pesé d'avis on peut le faire
d'entrée via des obstacles dans toute
action il ya des obstacles et il a et
persévérer cc croire que ça vaut la
peine
ça vaut la peine de tenir bon ça vaut la
peine pour le bien de tous ça vaut la
peine
et dans ce sens-là jésus-christ vient
nous aider à persévérer dans la
poursuite du billet dans la portée de ce
qui est juste à la portée de ce qui est
vrai de ce qui est beau se dire est
aussi dans la poursuite de la
miséricorde
parce que nous avons besoin de
miséricorde pour pour nous aider à nous
réconcilier les uns les autres nous
aider à vivre ensemble et aller de
l'avant ensemble on sert non seulement
chacun ou chacune pour soi d'aller
ensemble de l'avant reprenons quelques
instants de recueillement de silence
reprendre le tas vraiment au fond de
notre âme de plaisanter or notre père
notre grand-père notariale grand-père
notre ami notre frère les emprunts le
présente au seigneur pour qu'il
accueille avec la richesse marichez sa
miséricorde même temps avec l'ampleur de
la vie éternelle où il pourra exprimer
tous ses rêves
[Musique]
que notre prière montre maintenant
ardente est unanime vers dieu notre père
qui veut sauver tous les hommes et qui
attend notre prière que nous accorder le
don de sa grâce
souviens toi seigneur de ton amour pour
paul gérin lajoie qui reçu au bataclan
le germe de la vie éternelle afin qu'il
puisse se réjouir éternellement avec
tous les saints du ciel
prions le seigneur pour que tous les
enfants et les jeunes du monde est accès
à une éducation de qualité
prions le seigneur détruit mais owen to
work mort d'el hadj entendre a travaillé
avec diligence toujours accrue pour la
paix la justice la seconde mais grant
porte écluse du juge nous offrir la
patience et la fortitude et cela pour
tous ceux qui par la difficulté ou la
peine
partageant la passion de jésus christ
pour nous tous ici rassemblés pour ceux
qui n'ont pas pu venir
et pour ceux qui nous ont demandé de
prier pour eux prions le seigneur
pour la sainte église de dieu afin que
fidèle à la mission qu'elle a reçue elle
soit un ferment et une inspiration pour
la société et qu'elle réalise le mystère
de l'amour de dieu envers toutes les
personnes
prions le seigneur
accueil nos prières seigneur notre dieu
tué son père et tu as vu ton fils mourir
sur la croix fortifie notre france à des
élections ranime notre espérance dans la
vie que tu nous a promise par jésus le
christ notre seigneur
[Musique]
oh
non
[Musique]
et
l'eau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
son
[Musique]
on
m
en
[Musique]
prions ensemble au moment d'offrir le
sacrifice de toute l'église
en plaisantant seigneur cette offrande
pour le salut de ton serviteur paul nous
faisons appel à ton amour pas là
toujours vu un ton fils un sauveur plein
de bonté fait qu'il trouve maintenant en
libye le juge dont il n'a rien à
craindre par jésus le christ notre
seigneur
le skieur soit avec vous élevons notre
coeur dans nos grâce au seigneur notre
dieu
vraiment il est juste et bon de te
rendre noir d'offrir notre action de
grâce toujours et en tout lieu à troyes
perdrait son dieu éternel et tout
puissant par le christ notre seigneur
s'est enduit calais ce qu'en dit pour
nous l'espérance de la résurrection
bienheureuse
et si la loi de la mort nous afflige la
promesse de l'immortalité nous apporte
la consolation car pour tous ceux qui
croient en toi seigneur la vie n'est pas
détruite elle est transformée et lorsque
prend fait leur séjour sur la terre ils
ont déjà le demeure éternelle dans les
cieux c'est pourquoi avec les anges et
les archanges avec les puissances d'en
haut et tous les esprits bienheureux
nous sentons ligne de talloires est sans
fin nous proclamons
[Musique]
m
oh
ça
[Musique]
mais vraiment sain dieu de l'univers et
tout la création proclame ta louange car
c'est toi qui donne la vie c'est toi qui
sanctifie toute chose à mon fils
jésus-christ notre seigneur avec la
puissance de l'esprit saint et tu ne
cesses de l'assemblée ton peuple afin
qu'ils te présente partout dans le monde
une offrande pur c'est pourquoi nous
tous si fillon de consacrer 3 même les
offrandes que nous apportons sens qui
filait par ton esprit pour qu'elle
devienne le corps et le sang de ton fait
c'est jésus-christ notre seigneur qui
nous a dit de célébrer ce mystère la
nuit même où il fut livrée gris le pain
entravant gracile de benny hill le
rompit et le donne à ses disciples en
disant prenez et mangez en tous ceci est
mon corps livré pour vous
[Musique]
de même à la fin du repas il prit la
coupe en te rendant grâce il a béni la
donne à ses disciples en disant prenez
but les ans tous car ceci est la coupe
de mon sens le sens de l'alliance nouvel
éternel qui sera versée pour vous et
pour la multitude en rémission des
péchés
vous ferez cela en mémoire de moi
[Musique]
les grands mystères de la foi nous
claude la monte alors seigneur jésus
nous célébrons sa résurrection et nous
attendons à venu dans la loi en faisant
mémoire de ton fils de sa passion qui
nous sommes le sado lieu des élections
et de son ascension dans le ciel alors
que nous attendons son dernier
l'événement nous présentons cette
offrande vivant est sainte pour te
rendre grâce le gars du seigneur le
sacrifice de ton église et daigne de
connaître le circuit de ton fils qui
nous a rétabli dans son alliance
quand nous serons nous lit de son corps
et de son sang est rempli de l'esprit
saint accor de nous d'être seul corps et
de l'esprit dans le christ que
l'esprit-saint face de nous une
éternelle offrant data doigts pour que
nous obtenions un jour les biens du
monde à venir auprès de la vierge marie
la bienheureuse mère de dieu avec saint
joseph son époux avec les apôtres tous
les saints et saintes qui ne cesse
d'intercéder pour moi et maintenant nous
te prions le seigneur par le sacrifice
qui nous réconcilie avec toi et ton
monde entier
le saluent la bonne affermir la fois la
charité de donner glisse au long de ce
chemin sur la terre veille sur ton
serviteur le père françois
notre évêque son excellence monseigneur
christian lépine l'ensemble des élèves
les prêtres les diacres et tout le
peuple de racheter souviens toi de paul
que tu as appelé auprès de toi puisqu'il
a été baptisé dans la mort de ton face
aux accords de lui de participer à sa
résurrection le jour où le christ
ressuscitant les morts rendre à nous
pauvres corps pareil à son corps
glorieux
souviens toi aussi de nos frères et
soeurs défunt souviens-toi des humains
qui ont quitté ce monde et dont tu
connais la toiture se saouler dans ton
royaume où nous espérons être comblée de
talloires tous ensemble et pour
l'éternité
quand tu essuiera toute larme de nos
yeux en te voyant toi notre dieu tel que
tu es
nous te seront semblables éternellement
et sans fin nous chanterons ta louange
par le christ notre seigneur par qui se
donne au monde tout grâce et tout bien à
lui avec lui et en lui à toi dieu le
père tout puissant dans l'unité du
saint-esprit tout honneur et tout droit
pour les siècles des siècles unis dans
le même esprit nous pouvons dire avec
confiance la prière que nous avons reçu
du sauveur
notre père qui êtes aux cieux que ton
nom soit sanctifié que ton règne vienne
que ta volonté soit faite sur la terre
comme au ciel
donne nous aujourd'hui notre pain de ce
jour par de nous nos offenses comme nous
pardonnons aussi à ceux qui nous ont
offensés et de nous soumet pas sur la
tentation mais délivre nous du mal des
livres nous de tout mal seigneur et
donne la paix à notre temps par ta
miséricorde libère nous du péché bien
sûr nous demandait ses preuves dans
cette vie où nous espérons le bonheur
que tu promets et l'avènement de jésus
christ notre sauveur
seigneur jésus-christ tu as dit à tes
apôtres je vous laisse la paix je vous
donne ma paie ne regarde pas nos péchés
mais la foi de ton église pour que ta
volonté sa complice donne lui toujours
cette paix et conduit là vers l'unité
parfaite
toi qui règne pour les siècles des
siècles que la paix du seigneur soit
toujours avec vous
m
tu
oh
[Musique]
ans
bon
[Musique]
oh
on
[Musique]
oh
e
les invités au repas du seigneur voici
le nom de dieu quand lève le péché du
monde
seigneur je ne suis pas digne de
recevoir mais 10 seulement une parole et
je serai guéri
[Musique]
que
e
mais
oui
m
nous poursuivons notre couverture en
direct de la célébration des funérailles
nationales de cet ancien ministre de
l'éducation fondateur de la fondation
qui portait son nom de la dictée pgl
alors on parle ici bien sûr de paul
gérin lajoie la cathédrale actuellement
est bondée de dignitaires d'élus de
représentants politiques à la grandeur
du canada mais plusieurs pays de la
francophonie aussi en afrique en haïti
sont représentés actuellement
alors on a pensé une phase donc dans
cette cérémonie pendant laquelle il ya
eu plusieurs témoignages et des moyens
je vraiment très prenant très touchant
pierre duchesne et notre analyste
aujourd'hui père qui lui-même est un
ancien ministre de l'éducation qui est
auteur pierre repas sont un peu
justement ce qui ressortit dans ces
témoignages ont entendu le fils de paul
gérin lajoie françois il a parlé son
père en disant c'est un homme qui
voulait inspiré pour convaincre
il avait ce talent là c'était de
transmettre sa passion pour réussir à
mobiliser autour de lui il en a eu de
grands défis dansés vie il en a eu il
était exigeant il était entouré d'hommes
et de femmes qui étaient excessivement
talentueux on en a pas beaucoup parlé
mais arthur tremblay qui est devenu son
premier sous ministre était un homme qui
depuis 15-20 ans et tanvir cela valait
est un spécialiste en pédagogie en
éducation et avait aussi beaucoup il est
allé chercher cette table pour l'inde et
le discours dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure sur la politique internationale
du québec
c'était monsieur pat et andré patrick
est important de lancer la balle un
spécialiste il y en avait très peu à
l'époque des relations internationales
du québec dont il a su aussi à ccc le
talent d'un homme politique ou d'une
femme politique c'est de rassembler
d'aller chercher les meilleurs éléments
les faire travailler pour lui
il y aurait donc non qu'on pourrait
nommer comme ça alors il a travaillé
aussi dur et son fils françois à
construire ce qui est devenu le québec
inc
1 c'est à dire le québec des
entrepreneurs plus m'en parlait
justement cet aspect là il a dit on
parle d'éducation mais la domination la
soumission économique dans lequel les
québécois étaient en soit ça il ya eu
d'autres rapports sur la situation le
salaire moyen des québécois et les
québécois francophones étaient en bas en
terme de salaire moyen des italiens des
huttes laignel d'autres populations
immigrantes qui venaient au québec
portant dans des circonstances plus
difficile donc pour lui l'éducation
c'était la façon de aussi non seulement
les possibilités pour la jeunesse mais
de leur donner niveau de vie et ensuite
de créer toute une génération de
nouvelles entrepreneurs québécois et le
québec inc qui est habillée dans les
années 80 qui a été encouragé par
d'autres mesures mais vous aviez à tout
le moins la une formation au niveau
scolaire qui a permis de développer
l'économie du québec de pas raté l'an
2000 parce
gens craignaient que sinon on ne faisait
pas ces changements en 60
on a les ratés l'an 2000 au québec année
là il avait donc ce talent
extraordinaire d'être capable de se
projeter dans l'avenir il préparer les
générations futures
son fils françois parlait justement
d'importance à sa passion pour les
jeunes
il a dit il il portait toujours sur lui
un message il dit vous les jeunes prière
de rêver avec nous les vieux les sages
notre planète
on a bien besoin alors c'est vraiment ce
qu'on a entendu aussi dans les
témoignages quand on parlait de la
fondation à son nom
quand on parle de la fameuse dictée pgl
c'est vraiment c'est construire la
jeunesse voyez-y a été en politique on a
six ans il ya réussi à construire
quelque chose parce que c'est un homme
de la continuité
il n'était pas dans l'instantané dans la
manchette du jour
il était dans la continuité ces dossiers
ne se passait pas réaliser facilement
des gens s'opposent et lorsqu'il veut
absolument que le projet de loi sur une
salle d'éducation soient adaptés
rapidement il ya que deux ministres
sur la vingtaine qui vont l'appuyer et
il repart l'appui du premier ministre
donc ça va retarder le dépôt du projet
de loi
may a continué alors c'est un homme qui
avait une vision et était prêt à y aller
par étapes
d'ailleurs ils vont dire au commissaire
la commission parent ne me déposait pas
un rapport déposé en plusieurs
et moi je vais utiliser ça comme de
l'énergie que vous me donnez pour
pousser les réformes sur plusieurs
années harry pensait pas l'élection du
lent mais il pensait vraiment à
transformer adopter une structure
éducationnel pour les toutes les
générations de québécois at on entendu
sa petite fille julie aussi témoigné
parler de son grand père elle qui est
devenue avocate elle racontait
d'ailleurs j'ai son labo où la plus
jeune mais moins pluvieux
le plus vieux du barreau l'événement du
barreau donc elle à raconter une petite
anecdote où elle disait je me rappelle
nous a jamais empêché de faire du bruit
doux les petits enfants en eau à l étage
alors que lui avaient des rencontres
officielles en bas anecdote qui a été
reprise par le sud dans un témoignage
magnifique de dany laferrière on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir un petit peu plus
tard monseigneur 400 lépine a repris la
parole on va limiter les vivres dont
nous avons besoin pour la route qui mène
jusqu'à toi que cette eucharistie
permettent à notre frère paul de
parvenir à la table préparée dans ta
maison par jésus le christ notre
seigneur je vous invite à vous asseoir
au terme de cette célébration
et avant de passer au rite du dernier
adieu liturgique
je vous invite à écouter le message de
reconnaissance de cinq personnes qui ont
vécu à diverses époques
la dictée pgl j'ai la chance et
l'honneur depuis une dizaine d'années
d'agir à titre de porte parole de la
fondation paul gérin lajoie et d'animer
la grande finale internationale de la
dictée pgl une des créations
extraordinaires des actions durables de
paul gérin lajoie
on a parlé la dictée pgl va vivre cette
année sa 28e édition
chaque année des centaines de milliers
d'élèves d'ici et d'ailleurs participent
à cette dictée les vertus de ce projet
immense et porteurs sont nombreuses
évidemment valorisation du français
soutien des activités dans l'île des
activités dans les écoles
ouverture au monde ouverture aux autres
dépassement de soi solidarité mais à
chaque grande finale le moment que je
préférais ces moments où paul gérin
lajoie venait répondre aux questions des
jeunes participants il répondait avec
patience pertinence éloquence toutes les
questions des jeunes
il les faisait rire il faisait naître
dans leur tête de très belles idées il
semblait rajeunir à chaque fois je vous
présente deux gagnantes de la dictée pgl
qui sont pas mal plus grande aujourd'hui
qu'au moment de leur participation
d'abord elle a fait la dictée pgl en
2006 et aujourd'hui elle a une
spécialisation en histoire européenne et
le travail au journal de montréal
ariane la brèche quand j'ai appris le
décès de monsieur pas gérer la joie ça
me ramener un jour de mai en 2006
j'avais 12 ans j'avais des brunchs
j'avais une frange vraiment pas très
réussi puis c'est la première fois de ma
vie que je voyais une université en
rentrant dans le pavillon vincent d'indy
l'université de montréal est un grand
garçon qui est arrivé vers moi y avait
le sourire et a et cela je vais toujours
me rappeler
puis il venait de dakar au sénégal lui
aussi pour tenter sa chance à la dictée
pgl moi j'arrivais de drummondville et
c'était la première fois que je parlais
avec quelqu'un qui vivait sur un autre
continent
donc peut-être à savoir monsieur gérin
lajoie mot vers une première fenêtre sur
le monde mais il m'a aussi donné
confiance en moi ce serait un cadeau
inestimable pour une enfant de 12 ans
bien puisque l'orthographe c'est la
crise il de 40 des raisons qui m'a
transmise en fait l'important c'est
qu'il faut agir par conviction puisqu'on
peut jamais mesurer toute l'étendue des
gestes qu'on pose combien de vies
changent et par le travail et la
conviction de monsieur pas gérer la joie
on pourra jamais savoir
non vous voyons tous ici réunis
aujourd'hui je pense que je possède déjà
une partie de la réponse
merci merci à rien
je présente maintenant une autre
champion de la dictée pgl qui est
aujourd'hui animatrice radio télévision
ni soleil proteau bonjour d'où je viens
on ne se permet pas toujours de rêver
d'où je viens
on devient souvent adultes trop tôt mais
il y a aussi eu vous paul gérin lajoie
quand j'étais petite j'adorais la dictée
pgl et j'en suis devenue championne au
niveau international
c'est un moment que j'attendais avec
impatience
année après année dans mes petits yeux
d'enfants je vous voyais comme un géant
et vous l'étiez malgré votre immensité
vous preniez le temps de vous pencher à
ma hauteur de demander comment j'allais
me souhaiter bonne chance vous
reconnaissiez la magie de l'enfance et
aussi la fragilité qui vient avec
vous avez aimé vos enfants et votre
grande humanité vous a fait mais tous
les autres enfants aussi vous avez
contribué à mettre au monde des milliers
d'entre nous vous avez compris que ce
qu'on vit enfin nous suit pour le reste
de notre vie
vous avez fait en sorte que nous
puissions tous nous accomplir peu
importe d'où l'on vient je me souviens
de cette phrase qui est la vôtre
si tu peux y rêver tu peut le réaliser
vous m'avez appris à rêver et à me
réaliser votre dictée c'était mon sport
à moi vous m'avez donné le goût de la
langue française le goût de me dépasser
et le goût de réussir et nous sommes
plusieurs comme ça si je réalise chaque
jour mon grand rêve de parler aux gens
de chez nous à la télévision et à la
radio
c'est en partie grâce à vous je suis une
petite fille d'hochelaga acquis pgl a
donné des ailes
merci monsieur aujourd'hui
et pour longtemps encore votre oeuvre et
votre carte g1 continueront de vivre
merci à du soleil
je vous présente maintenant deux
participants à la dictée pgl elliott et
kate
je participe à la dictée pgl depuis
maintenant sept ans de ma première
participation au préscolaire
on m'a expliqué qu'ils étaient ce grand
homme qui t'est pas j'irai ajoie la
dictée pgl mari elle manque va l'esprit
sur le monde en me permettant
d'apprendre sur différentes cultures qui
nous entoure et ce de façon ludique et
agréable
j'ai également appris que le français
était parlée dans plusieurs pays
la dictée pgl m'a aussi permis
d'améliorer mon français en apprenant de
nouveaux mots
si je n'avais pas participé à la dictée
plus cher je n'en serai pas autant sur
le monde qui nous entoure
c'est pour cela qu'il faut continuer et
encourager ce très bel héritage que nous
a légué monsieur paul gérin lajoie
petit tpg elle m'a beaucoup influencé un
des messages importants de ce projet
éducatif c'est que tout le monde devrait
avoir un accès facile à l'éducation
cela m'a ouvert les yeux sur la réalité
des jeunes dans d'autres pays je sais
qu'en participant à la dictée je peux
faire une différence ici et ailleurs
dans le monde
personnellement ça me donne le goût de
m'engager davantage à mon école je me
suis même impliqué dans d'autres
activités comme une soirée cinéma afin
d'amasser plus de sous pour les projets
de la fondation un arctique et en haïti
tout comme monsieur paul gérin lajoie
j'ai pour moi aussi changer le monde
merci qu'être merci elliott la famille
souhaitait qu'une chanson d'yves duteil
soit interprété aujourd'hui monsieur
duteil a fait le voyage de france pour
être avec nous je vais lui demander de
nous expliquer d'où est venue l'idée de
cette chanson bien c'est paul gérin
lajoie lui même qui m'a demandé de
l'écrit il a souhaité qu'on se rencontre
lors d'une de mes tournées au québec il
y a une vingtaine d'années à peu près et
cette rencontre a été programmée devait
durer 30 minutes la durée 3 heures mais
tu es mon épouse et moi mon épouse
noëlle et moi fasciné par la
bienveillance qui émanait de cet homme
sa force de conviction et puis cette
volonté incroyable de transmission qui
nous a énormément ému et donc il m'a
demandé si j'accepterais d'écrire une
chanson pour le 25e anniversaire de la
fondation pgl et j'ai accepté bien sûr
et puis je suis reparti nous sommes
d'ailleurs repartis avec la richesse de
cette conversation et j'ai écrit à
prendre et j'entendais françois tout à
l'heure qui parlait d'un esprit lumineux
c'est exactement ce qu'on a ressenti
avec noël c'est paul gérin lajoie était
pour nous et restera toujours pour nous
un passeur un passeur de lumière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le soleil la terre se fend pour 7 ans et
pour son enfant
après le puits qu'il faut creuser reste
un sillon tracé
sans attendre
à lire à écrire à compter voulait porter
encore fermés sur ce sa voix cumulées
qu'on lui en donne un jour la clean il
est le monde sa portée
v
ma propre ville entre l'ailé
découvrir la magie d'ici les trésor
inépuisable pendant porte dans son coeur
[Musique]
comprendre
comme un mur et l'on traverse
c'est la brume qui se dispersent
une promesse encore plus belle
la connaissance universelle
monter
apprendre compter sur soi-même
à compter pour ceux qui vous aiment pour
faire aussi partie du nom
pouvoir enfin
sortir de long
on prend
oui à la vie chrétienne se perd
mais ce maître a compté pour elle
faire la somme de sa différence et se
soustrait la ligne oran
écrit
à prendre avec son histoire
à la plume et aux créances
impliquant son écriture
apporter sa propre aventure
[Musique]
sur train
c'est mon nom me des flammes
semer des graines au long des quais
confier son art et sa mémoire à celui
qui viendra plus tard
[Musique]
pour cet enfant à son pupitre
tirer la langue sur le titre
écrire son nom sur son cahier s'est
plongé sa liberté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et vous asseoir
permettez moi de profiter de cette
occasion pour remercier chaleureusement
les artistes qui ont apporté une
contribution exceptionnelle à cette
célébration de ce gregory charles
madame johanne blouin monsieur yves
duteil madame mireille siegel à l'orgue
remercions les généreusement
[Applaudissements]
le vent nous pour le dernier adieu
notre frère paul s'est endormi dans la
paix du christ
confions de à l'amour de dieu notre père
dans la foi en la vie éternelle avec
respect et affection accompagnons notre
prière dans l'espérance de nous
retrouver un jour quand dieu nous
réunira dans la joie de son royaume
réveillons nous en passant tout ce que
nous avons vécu avec paul à ce qu'il est
pour nous à ce qu'il est pour dieu en
signe de respect voici cet ancien qu'il
monte devant dieu avec notre prière nous
espérons nous croyons que tous nous
ressusciterons en signe de cette fois je
vais ni le cas de paul veuillez vous
asseoir
[Musique]
[Musique]
e
m
[Musique]
on
or
[Musique]
oh
à
on est rendus maintenant dans cette
cérémonie que nous diffusions en direct
sur nos ondes ses funérailles nationales
de paul gérin lajoie à l'étape de la
signature des registres et par la suite
il y aura la remise du drapeau à la
faible hyper c'est un beau symbole cette
remise du drapeau
c'est le drapeau qui a été mis en berne
à l'annoncé du décès de paul gérin
lajoie sur la tour centrale du parlement
de la somme et rational c'est donc un
tableau géant parce que du sol il a pas
l'air très gras mais il est géante
disproportionnée et il est pliée selon
deux formules remis dans un boîtier et
c'est un hommage que le premier surnom
de la nation qui veut c'est lié à notre
dignité recommandons notre frère paul
mon amour l'accompagner tout au long de
sa vie les livres eux maintenant de tout
mal
il a quitté ce monde qui passe conduit
lait auprès de toi où il n'y a plus ni
deuil ni l'armée ni douleur mais la joie
et la paix avec ton fils et l'esprit
saint pour les siècles des siècles le
seigneur soit avec vous
que dieu tout puissant vous bénisse le
père le fils et le saint-esprit que
toutes marques d'affection tout geste
d'amitié que vous donnerez soit pour vos
signes de cette paix qu ensemble nous
avons cherché à l'est dans la paix du
christ
m
[Musique]
à nous deux c'est
après tout
[Musique]
les français
massi est flou
autre fugitif
[Musique]
c'est vous
au courant penny mon pays m'a dit tu
vois
oui
mon pays malheureux
faty je me souviens
vaty raté
[Applaudissements]
j'ai sous
ou pas
ou cette autre histoire
[Musique]
bonjour vous êtes disparu
et mon père
[Musique]
je fais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
longer nominé mano chez nous
loin de mes chers parents je passais
trop nombreux
infos reçues j'ai passé trop
un forte eu des moments
pour jamais c'est paris
[Musique]
on jamais
il m'arrive
ses amis de
et la seule
et ça
e
mais un seul est
[Musique]
non mais on expire ans
mon cher canada
mais mon cher
on regarde long
tissot
verte ou pas c'est pas mal
monte carlo
[Musique]
faire toi c
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà la cérémonie d'hier maintenant à
c'est fait donc avec cette chanson il
faudra compter pierre duchesne
l'histoire de cette chanson cette
chanson très connue qui fait vraiment
partie de notre folklore québécois un
canadair
oui c'est un appel à l'histoire du
québec a la nostalgie c'est enfin
l'arrière grand père de paul gérin
lajoie qui a composé cette chanson à
l'âge de 15 ans il est au collège
classique
ces quelques années après la rébellion
des patriotes de 1837-1838 dont vers
1840 2 et les patriots certains d'entre
eux ont été condamnés politiques ont été
exilés très loin de leur pays pour sa
console l'onel la tristesse du canadien
en australie en tasmanie donc exilés
politiques et son arrière grand père qui
était très jeune donc composent cette
chanson dans son collège et ça devient
un classique et voyez ça n'a plus de
presque même
quasiment 200 ans maintenant et c'est
une chanson qui est demeuré alors c'est
quand même une surprise parce que de
voir un tel bien sûr y ait un lien
familial
mais là il ya un appel au passé et cette
vision de ce pays qu'il qu'il ne reverra
plus alors c'est quand même inite
mais l'auteur donc s'appelait antoine
villageois points en jeu et c'est très
intéressant de remonter nos l'arbre
généalogique justement des gérer la joie
quand on regarde la petite histoire on
voit que leur le premier la famille
il met d'abord de savoie en france
premier représentant jean gérer donc ce
n'était pas gervais lajoie était sergent
dans les troupes de montcalm et qu'il
avait la réputation d'être de bel hubert
donc surnommée la joie et finalement ce
surnom à transformer leur nom de famille
ils sont devenus les gérer le jeu c'est
quand même une très jolie histoire
oui et on voit que cette famille
plusieurs membres de la famille sont
liés a justement plusieurs épisodes
importants de l'histoire du québec
et lui il va regarder une place je
dirais d'honneur
et en ce premier ministre de l'éducation
et tout le rôle clé joué par la suède
pour les forêts les fables dans cette
famille il ya deux grandes dames dans un
ami c est derrière le projet on en a
parlé au début mais il faut le rappeler
il la réforme de l'éducation a avant
tout et surtout profité aux jeunes
femmes ou jeunes filles qui n'avaient
pas accès distant été inéquitable
totalement pour l'heure la jeune fille
et ça c'est une c'est une vraiment la
révolution tranquille porte son éclat le
plus beau dans les gares de cette de
réforme là parce que ç'a permis à des
générations de jeunes filles dont ils
ont le voit plus tard on a vu ses
anciennes je ne les enchante les
gagnants des ivg de la famille du
mouvement vous aviez madame anne marie
anne soleil proteau qui dit moi je viens
de chagall l'endroit où le rêve est
peut-être pas facile mais vous m'avez
déjà rêver et gl était une grande
gagnante de la dictée donc on voit qu'il
a semé l'espoir et à donner des
résultats
innombrables elle a rappelé les mots
d'ailleurs deux notions gérin lajoie et
on la sentait extrêmement ému pendant
son témoignage dont kanye soleil proteau
qui a dit il tenait toujours et son fils
françois le disait aussi si tu peux y
rêver tu peut le réaliser et on sent que
c'était vraiment le mantra de monsieur
gérin lajoie vraiment c'est ce qui l'a
porté tout au long de sa vie et il dit
est il utilisé le mot un passeur un
c'est un passeur de lire tout ça très
beau aussi parce que ya l'espoir mais le
passé les distribuer illuminait les eaux
alors très jolie histoire aussi raconté
par yves duteil kyi a rencontré pour
gérer la joie la demande de paul gérin
lajoie qui était très inspiré par les
chansons des items et monsieur gérin
lajoie lui a fait une commande
complètement n'a vraiment d'écrire une
chanson sur mesure pour souligner les 25
ans de la fameuse dictée pgl unique
chanson avec des paroles ou vraiment
toutes les valeurs de l'alphabétisation
se retrouvant avec sadie apprend sadique
rire sadique comptait alors on sent
vraiment le travail pour que cette
chanson soit collée sur l'esprit qui
anime d'injecter gère ya des très belles
phrases je mens jamais notre hymne
comprendre c'est comme un mur que l'on
traverse est tout tout son taxi est
bordée de deux belles de belles phrases
comme ceux liés à l'alphabétisation
l'éducation
à la liberté au latin dans n'est pas
éduqué existe un d'ailleurs je peux
permettre de mentionner que je vais
recevoir en entrevue
aujourd'hui l'émission à 24,60 donc il
nous racontera justement l'impression
que lui a laissés paul gérin lajoie
lors de leur rencontre il ya plusieurs
années alors vous voyez ici mesdames
messieurs l'image du corbillard qui est
entré de quitter les lieux de la
basilique cathédrale pour aller porter
monsieur gérin lajoie sur le site de son
dernier repos quand on vit aussi sur les
mots qui nous ont frappés pendant mes
témoignages dany laferrière ça a été
vraiment c'était du grand délit
laferrière c'était vraiment extrêmement
émouvant et il a dit ceci je suis
vraiment au texte y dit j'ai dit paul
gérin lajoie est mort mais 26 lettres de
l'alphabet pétillante tout plein de joie
d'énergie de guetter le ceni est clair
son chemin vers l'immortalité
mais c'est pas mal et tout ça sans notes
et avec une éloquence
alors il est un élément de l'académie
française est de toute évidence il a
utilisé tout son talent d'écrivain il
est inspiré études j'ai de très bons
mots c'est un honneur poétique les
pressentis il y a
non ça c'était mais c'est une cérémonie
avec beaucoup de témoignages très riches
seulement parce qu'on est en mesure de
bien peser la l'importance de l'homme
puissent capter toute sa dimension de
toutes les étapes de sa vie et de tous
les volets de son engagement se nomme
que plusieurs visent une certaine façon
et qui a parcouru plusieurs générations
donc il est inspiré les gens de son hip
hop là il était jeune et ce qu'on
comprend aujourd'hui au travers de ce
témoignage qu'il inspire encore
aujourd'hui est que cette inspiration va
transcender la mort finalement elle va
rester parmi nous est ce qu'elle peut
inspirer les politiciens actuels ou tel
autre campagne électorale je ne sais pas
il est intéressant que la cérémonie ait
lieu dans un moment de précampagne une
chose certaine
comme comme homme politique il y avait
six ans il laisse une trace bien
particulière c'est à dire c'est un homme
d'idées
c'est un homme qui installent des
politiques qui c'est qui qui prennent du
temps
donc le temps normalement doit être un
allié des grandes réformes et un veau
lyon valiant de capital et souvent c'est
chaque journée marque vraiment la fin de
la fin d'un monde
alors je vais produire et la joie moi je
reviens là dessus s'est installé dans la
continuité y regarder le sens de sa vie
parce que même après la création d'une
salle d'éducation
il était dans l'aide internationale et
avec la fondation est de continuer à
aider il c'est une boucle
parce que c'est l'éducation si l'école
si le savoir si le savoir l'endroit des
plus démunis ou s'il l'a pas fait à
l'endroit des il est allé en afrique et
ailleurs donc ça c'est des gestes porter
bien duchesne merci de nous avoir
accompagnés tout au long de cette
émission spéciale
alors voilà on va conclure là-dessus
mesdames et messieurs merci d'avoir et
puis avec nous et on reviendra sur la
programmation dernier
et dans nos différentes et les journaux
aussi sur les moments forts de cette
cérémonie sur les témoignages
vous pouvez d'ailleurs les retrouver sur
notre plate forme avec notre appli
radio-canada fo sur notre page web aussi
de radio canada.ca
et comme je vous dis cette entrevue à ne
pas manquer ce soir à l'émission 24 60
sur vers 10 à 19 heures avec yves duteil
et on reviendra aussi sur les principaux
témoignages de tous ces dignitaires qui
était présent aujourd'hui alors voilà je
vais céder l'antenne mais tant la
programmation régulière l'émission
l'info sur les ondes de rdi merci
d'avoir été avec nous bonne fin de
journée au revoir
[Musique]